A QUORUM IS PRESENT IN THE
ASSEMBLY.
WE HAVE SET OUR GUESTS AND
VISITORS IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER AND IN THE GALLERY.
PLEASE STAND FOR THE PRAYER
.
TODAY'S PRAYER.
WILL BE OFFERED BY OUR ASSEMBLY
CHAPLAIN.
REVEREND BOB OSHITA REVEREND
OSHITA.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN A MOMENT OF
REFLECTION.
THERE CAN BE NO DEEPER OR MORE
MEANINGFUL BOND.
THEN BETWEEN LOVING PARENT AND
CHILD. FOR SUCH BONDS OF LOVE.
ARE THE BONDS OF LIFE ITSELF.
THIS HAS BEEN SO FROM THE DAWN
OF HUMANKIND.
THE DEPTH OF THIS BOND IS
EXPRESSED IN THE ANCIENT COME
UPON THE SCRIPTURES.
CREATED OVER TWO THOUSAND SIX
HUNDRED YEARS AGO.
OF THE BOND OF PARENT AND CHILD
IT IS WRITTEN.
A LOVING PARENT WILL SAY TO
THEIR CHILD.
IT IS ALRIGHT FOR ME TO GROW OLD.
IT IS ALRIGHT FOR ME TO BECOME
ILL.
IT IS ALRIGHT FOR ME TO DIE.
BUT NOT YOU [inaudible]
NOT YOU.
THE LOVING CHILDLESS SAY TO
THEIR PARENTS.
NO.
IT IS ALRIGHT FOR ME TO ROLL.
IT IS ALRIGHT FOR ME TO BECOME
ILL.
IT IS ALRIGHT FOR ME TO DIE.
BUT NOT YOU [inaudible]
NOT YOU. FOR SUCH IS THE DEEP
NATURE OF THE LOVE SHARED BY
PARENT AND CHILD.
IT IS TRULY THE BOND OF LIFE
ITSELF.
EACH OF US THAT HAS HAD TO NOTE
THE DEEP LOSS OF A PARENT OR
CHILD.
WE KNOW THIS FEELING TO BE
UNDENIABLY CHIU.
WE KNOW THIS BOND OF LIFE.
IS IN IMMEASURABLE AND
UNBREAKABLE VIAL OF LOVE.
THAT IS TRY TO LIVE HONORING
THIS DEEP.
UNIVERSAL BOND OF LIFE AND LOVE.
BETWEEN ALL PARENTS AND CHILDREN.
NUMBER ONE SWEET KINDNESS
INGRATITUDE BEYOND WORDS.
THANK YOU REVEREND WE ASK OUR
GUESTS AND VISITORS TO REMAIN
STANDING.
AND PLEASE JOIN US FOR THE FLAG
SALUTE PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER QUIRK SILVA AS HE LEADS
US IN THE PLEDGE MISSED QUIRK
SILVA.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN SALUTING OUR
FLAG.
I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE [inaudible]
IT'S A I WISH.
I KNEW ABOUT.
IT IS A TEENAGERS.
THANK YOU YOU MAY BE SEATED.
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL ASSEMBLY CHAMBER
SACRAMENTO VERSION SEVEN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN THE CEMENT AT
NINE AM AUDIBLE KEVIN MULLIN
SPEAKER.
DECIDING SHE THIRTY DECIBELS IN
AT THE DESK READING CLERK
KATHLEEN LOS READING THE ROLES
CALL ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAIENSCHEIN
MISTER CALDERON MOVES.
AND MR MAIENSCHEIN SECONDS.
THAT THE READING OF THE PREVIOUS
DAY'S JOURNAL BE DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS OF PETITIONS THERE
ARE NONE.
INTRODUCTION AND REFERENCE OF
BILLS WILL BE DEFERRED.
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR THERE
ARE NONE.
MESSAGES FROM THE SENATE.
THERE ARE NONE.
MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS.
THE ABSENCES FOR THE DAY. FOR
LEGISLATIVE BUSINESS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER IN THE KAMLAGER-DOVE OF
AS WELL AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER BRIAN
DALLY. FOR PERSONAL BUSINESS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER [inaudible]
THEY'LL GROW.
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR PROCEDURAL
MOTIONS THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE ONE
EIGHTEEN A TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLYMEMBER EGGMAN. TO HAVE
GUESTS AND PHOTOGRAPHERS ON THE
FLOOR TODAY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
AIKMAN'S GUESTS WILL BE SEATED
AT HER DESK.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER.
I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY FIVE
POINT FIVE ALLOW THE SPEAKER AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS O'DONNELL AND
BAKER TO SPEAK ON A GERMAN IN
MEMORY TODAY.
AGAIN WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER.
I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND JOINT RULE SIXTY TWO WAY
THE FILE NOTICE REQUIREMENT TO
ALLOW THE INSURANCE COMMITTEE TO
HEAR S. B.. TWELVE FORTY EIGHT
GAINES TODAY AND ROOM FOR FORTY
SEVEN UPON A GERMAN ASSERTION.
AND AGAIN WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER PURSUANT TO
ASSEMBLY RULE NINETY SIX I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO RE
REFER THE FOLLOWING BILL TO
COMMITTEE.
SB FIVE SIXTY ONE GAINS FROM
ELECTIONS AND REDISTRICTING
COMMITTEE TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE [inaudible]
WITHOUT OBJECTION.
AT THE REQUET OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GONZALEZ FLETCHER PLEASE
REMOVE ITEM A NINETEEN S. B. TWO
SEVEN THREE HILL FROM THE ENACT
A FILE.
THE CLERK WILL KNOW.
MEMBERS IF YOU'LL ALLOW ME I
HAVE SOME SPECIAL GAS THAT HAVE
ARRIVED IN THE GALLERY.
TODAY I'D LIKE TO INTRODUCE THE
PRESIDENT OF THE PACIFIC A
SCHOOL BOARD THE HONORABLE
ELIZABETH PER DAHLE HER TWO SONS
JOHN AND MARK AS WELL AS A
TEACHER FROM PACIFIC OUT MISS
JESSICA MERCADO THEY ARE LOCATED
IN THE GALLERY PLEASE WELCOME
THEM TO THE ASSEMBLY TODAY
.
MEMBERS THANK EVERY ATTENTION.
WE HAVE ADDITIONAL SPECIAL GAS
IN THE CHAMBER.
I SEE THAT DOCTOR EGGMAN HAS VIP
ON THE FLOOR.
DOCTOR AB AND YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FROM YOUR DESK.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER I AM GLAD TO BRING MY
LITTLE GIRL UP HER ANNUAL TRIP
AFTER SHE GRADUATES FOURTH GRADE.
HEADING INTO FIFTH WORD
CURRENTLY SHE IS ICE SKATING ON
A SWIM TEAM AND HER FAVORITE
MOVIE THAT WE'VE SEEN
[inaudible]
COUNTLESS TIMES THE GREATEST
SHOWMAN [inaudible]
I MEAN
MEMBERS WE HAVE
ADDITIONAL GAS WITH US IN THE
CHAMBER TODAY PLEASE KEEP YOUR
ATTENTION MEMBERS TO MISTER
HOLDEN.
MISTER HOLDEN HAS A SPECIAL
INTRODUCTION MEMBERS
[inaudible]
MR HOLDING.
THANK YOU MISER SPEAKER AS
CHAIR OF THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS AND
TOGETHER WITH SPEAKER RENDON.
I AM PROUD TO WELCOME THE
MANDELA WASHINGTON FELLOWS TO
THE CALIFORNIA STATE ASSEMBLY.
THE MANDELA WASHINGTON FELLOWS
IS AS PRESTIGIOUS EMPOWERING
FLAGSHIP PROGRAM A TWENTY FIVE
YOUNG PROFESSIONALS FROM
SUBSAHARAN AFRICA.
REPRESENTING OVER SEVENTEEN
DIFFERENT COUNTRIES.
THESE DISTINGUISHED YOUNG
LEADERS ARE IN THE U. S. AS PART
OF AN ACADEMIC.
AND LEADERSHIP INSTITUTE IN
ORDER TO ADVANCE ENERGY.
POLICIES.
BUSINESS STRATEGIES AND
TECHNOLOGIES WITH THE FOCUS ON
THE SUSTAINABILITY OF THE ENERGY
SECTOR FROM AN ENVIRONMENTAL AND
ECONOMIC STANDPOINT.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN WELCOMING THE
ACCOMPLISH DONE LEADERS OF THE
MANDELA WASHINGTON FELLOWSHIP
.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO
BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE
[inaudible]
SECOND READING [inaudible]
CORKERY.
SENATE BILL EIGHTEEN NINETY
SEVEN SMALL SIXTY THREE WITH A
MARRIAGE TO SEVENTY FIVE HAVE
BEEN MUCH LOVE FIFTY TWO WITH
AMENDMENTS TO SOME BEFORE THE
MINUTE SEVEN TWENTY SIX OF THE
MEN INSTALL TWENTY EIGHT WITH A
MEMBERS FOURTEEN SOME BEFORE THE
MINUTES WILL THIRTY EIGHT
MINUTES. TWELVE BEFORE THE
MINUTE'S 910-940-71030
511-921-2405. FOURTEEN FIFTEEN
FOURTEEN TWENTY SEVEN SEVENTY
FIVE TWENTY TWO SIX EIGHTY EIGHT
SEVEN SIXTY SIX EIGHT SIXTEEN
NINE TWENTY NINE TWENTY NINE
NINE FORTY TWO NINE NINETY SEVEN
TO THREE TEN FORTY TO TEN NINETY
EIGHT ELEVEN THIRTEEN ELEVEN
FIFTY THREE ELEVEN NINETY NINE
TOTALLY. TWELVE TWENTY SEVEN
TWELVE THIRTY TO TWELVE THIRTY
NINE TWELVE EIGHTY THIRTEEN
THIRTY ONE THIRTEEN SIXTY THREE
FIFTEEN HUNDRED THIRTEEN OH SIX
FOUR NINETY FIVE THE MINUTES SIX
NINETY ONE OF THE MEMBERS
FIFTEEN A ONE THIRTEEN OH FOR
THE MEN INSTANCE EVERY NIGHT
WITH AMENDMENTS.
TOLL FIFTY FORTY ONE ELEVEN
NINETY SIX ANSWER THE BILL A
TWENTY FOUR ALL BILLS HAVE BEEN
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
DEEMED ADOPTED.
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AT THE
REQUEST OF THE AUTHORS PLEASE
REMOVE THE FOLLOWING BILLS FROM
THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
ITEM TWENTY S. B. SIX EDA
MORLOCK. THREE MORE LOCK AND I
TO NINETY FIVE S. B. TEN FIFTY
FIVE BRADFORD.
THE CLERK WILL KNOW
.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO MOVE TO
THE CONCURRENCE FILE.
THIS IS CONCURRENCE MEMBERS FILE
ITEMS FIFTY ONE AND FIFTY TWO
PASS AND RETAIN.
THAT BRINGS US TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER.
FIFTY THREE AB TWENTY THREE
ELEVEN MEMBERS.
LOTS OF BUSINESS BEFORE THE
HOUSE TODAY PLEASE KEEP YOUR
CONVERSATIONS TO A MINIMUM.
THIS IS FILE ITEM FIFTY THREE AB
TWENTY ONE THIRTEEN CORPORATION.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY ONE
THIRTEEN BY SOME REMEMBER
OBERNOLTE ACRYLATE ESTATES AND
TRUSTS.
MR OBERNOLTE THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AB TWENTY ONE THIRTEEN
WOULD CLARIFY THAT A GUARDIAN
RETAINS FINANCIAL CONTROL OVER
THE STATE OF AWARD IN THE EVENT
OF THE DEATH OF THAT WARD UNTIL
SUCH TIME.
AS THEY ARE RELIEVED BY A
PROBATE COURT THIS BILL HAS HAD
NO OPPOSITION AND HAS RECEIVED
UNANIMOUS SUPPORT I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER OBERNOLTE
SEEING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE.
QUIRK LOVE THEY'RE ALL.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE?
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE?
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE THE
ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT ABOUT.
CLARK WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT I
SIXTY SEVEN NO ZERO THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS.
OUR CONCURRED IN.
FILE ITEMS. FIFTY FOUR FIFTY
FIVE AND FIFTY SIX PASS A RETAIN
THAT BRINGS US TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER.
FIFTY SEVEN AB FIFTEEN TWENTY
SEVEN THE CARBERY.
SOME PEOPLE FIFTEEN TWENTY SEVEN
BY SOME MEMBERS ALSO AND OTHERS
AND I PLAYED A CANNABIS A
DECLARATIVE SET UP THAT PICKED
ME DEEPLY.
MISTER JONES SAWYER.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB
FIFTEEN TWENTY SEVEN WAS A
MINUTE AND IS SENATE TO CLARIFY
THAT THE LEGISLATURE HAS THE
AUTHORITY TO REMOVE THEIR
APPOINTEES FROM THE CANNABIS
CONTROL APPEALS PANEL.
LAST YEAR SENATE BILL NINETY
FOUR ATTITUDE LEGISLATIVE
APPOINTMENTS TO APPEALS PANEL IN
ADDITION TO THE THREE MEMBERS
APPOINTED BY THE GOVERNOR.
HOWEVER LANGUAGE IN S. B. NINETY
FOUR DID NOT INCLUDE.
BLESSED AUTHORIZATION FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO REMOVE THOSE
IMPORT APPOINTEES AS A RESULT
PANEL MEMBERS APPOINTED BY THE
LEGISLATURE COULD SERVE ON THE
PANEL INDEFINITELY.
AB FIFTEEN TWENTY SEVEN WERE
CLEAR FIND STATUTE THAT
APPOINTEE TO THE CANVAS CONTROL
APPEALS PANEL SERVE AT THE
PLEASURE OF THEIR APPOINTING
AUTHORITY.
MEMBERS ARE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE ON CONCURRENT WITH
SENATE AMENDMENT.
THANK YOU MR ELSEWHERE SEEING NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
QUICK LOVE THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS
VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
BURKE NO ZERO ON THE MEASURE.
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN.
FILE ITEM FIFTY EIGHT HOUSE
RETAIN.
RECONSIDERATION ITEM SIXTY TWO
SIXTY THREE AND SIXTY FOUR WILL
BE CONTINUED.
ON ASSEMBLY THIRD READING FILE
ITEM SIXTY FIVE THROUGH
[inaudible]
SIXTY EIGHT PAIN.
MEMBERS AROUND THE SENATE THIRD
READING [inaudible]
FILE.
THIS IS SENATE [inaudible]
THIRD READING.
FILE ITEM SIXTY NINE AND SEVENTY
PASS A RETAIN.
WERE FOUND OVER SEVENTY ONE SB
ELEVEN OH SEVEN CLERK WILL READ
SENATE BILL ELEVEN OH SEVEN BY
CENTER LEYVA ACCOLADE PUBLIC
SOCIAL SERVICES.
MS RAMOS YOU MAY OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
S. B. ELEVEN OH SEVEN WOULD
ALLOW ANY NONPROFIT OR FOR
PROFIT AGENCY TO PARTICIPATE IN
THE VENDORS NATION PROCESS
THROUGH DEPARTMENT OF OF
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES.
SO THAT THEY CAN PROVIDE FAMILY
HOME AGENCY SERVICES.
CALIFORNIA HAS RIGHTFULLY
PRIORITIZE PROVIDING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR ADULTS WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES TO
LIVE WITH FAMILIES AND RECEIVE
SUPPORT AND SERVICES IN A FAMILY
SETTING. FOR SOME THE FAMILY
HOME MODEL OFFERS A LESS
RESTRICTIVE ALTERNATIVE TO GROUP
HOME AND INTERMEDIATE CARE
FACILITY SETTINGS.
THESE PROVIDERS TEACH LIFE
SKILLS LIFE SKILLS BASED ON THE
NEEDS OF THE INDIVIDUAL WITHIN
THE HOME SETTING SUCH AS
GROOMING HYGIENE SCHEDULING AND
TRANSPORTATION. FOR APPOINTMENTS
AND SUPPORT FOR OTHER ACTIVITIES
SUCH AS SCHOOL WORK AND
RECREATION.
IN CALIFORNIA IN CALIFORNIA BOTH
NONPROFIT AND FOR PROFIT
COMPANIES PROVIDE MEDI CAL
WAIVERS AN INTERMEDIATE CARE
FAMILY SERVICES.
BUT WE CURRENTLY LIMIT MEDI CAL
FAMILY HOME AGENCY SERVICES TO
ONLY NONPROFIT AGENCIES WHICH
GREATLY AFFECT THE FLEXIBILITY
THAT FAMILIES HAVE WHEN CHOOSING
CARE AND RESOURCES. FOR THEIR
LOVED ONES.
THIS BILL WILL NOT CHANGE THE
QUALIFICATIONS FOR PROVIDERS
MEANING THAT BOTH FOR PROFIT AND
NOT FOR PROFITS.
WOULD HAVE THE SAME STANDARDS
OVERSIGHT AND CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS BY ALLOWING ANY
NONPROFIT OR FOR PROFIT AGENCY
TO PARTICIPATE.
IN THE VENDORS NATION PROCESS SP
ELEVEN OH SEVEN WILL INCREASE
THE OPPORTUNITY AND FLEXIBILITY
FOR PEOPLE WITH INTELLECTUAL.
AND DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
TO LIVE IN A FAMILY SETTING.
IT'S BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION AND
HAS RECEIVED UNANIMOUS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MS RACE.
SEEING NO MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION ON THE ITEM.
CLERK WILL UP THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO'S THERE NOT ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT I
SIXTY NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WE ARE FILE ITEM NUMBER.
SEVENTY TWO THAT IS S. B.
[inaudible]
ELEVEN SEVENTY ONE COOPERATE.
SENATE BILL ELEVEN SEVENTY ONE
BY SUITOR STERN ACCOLADE TO
ELECTIONS [inaudible]
MISTER BERMAN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS THIS MORNING I'MHERE TO
PRESENT S. B. ELEVEN SEVENTY ONE
ON BEHALF OF SENATOR STERN.
SB ELEVEN SEVENTY ONE PERMITS
COUNTY ELECTIONS OFFICIALS TO
USE PROVISIONAL BALLOT ENVELOPES
FOR VOTER REGISTRATION PURPOSES
PROVIDED THEY INCLUDE ALL THE
INFORMATION CURRENTLY INCLUDED
ON AN AFFIDAVIT OF REGISTRATION.
MEMBERS THERE ARE INSTANCES
WHERE VOTERS ARE REQUIRED TO
COMPLETE AN AFFIDAVIT OF
REGISTRATION.
AND A PROVISIONAL BALLOT
ENVELOPE EVEN THOUGH.
MUCH OF THE INFORMATION REQUIRED
ON BOTH FORMS IS IDENTICAL.
BY MERGING TWO FORMS TO ONE FORM
S. B. ELEVEN SEVENTY ONE WILL
SAVE MONEY AND STAFF TIME BY
ALLOWING PROVISIONAL VOTERS TO
REGISTER FULLY BY COMPLETING THE
REQUESTED INFORMATION.
ON A PROVISIONAL BALLOT ENVELOPE
WITHOUT HAVING TO ADDITIONALLY
FILL OUT A DUPLICATIVE AFFIDAVIT
OF REGISTRATION.
THIS BILL IS SPONSORED BY
SECRETARY OF STATE.
SUPPORTED BY THE LEAGUE OF WOMEN
VOTERS OF CALIFORNIA THIS BILL
HAS NO OPPOSITION AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER BERMAN
.
DOCTOR CHOI YOUR RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU SPEAKER AND A MEMBERS
SAW I RISE.
TODAY IN OPPOSITION OF US SENATE
BILL.
ELEVEN SEVENTY ONE THIS BILL SIX
TO ALLOW ON UNREGISTERED THE
VOTER TO REGISTER FOR ME NOT BY
COMPLETING A VOTER REGISTRATION
FORM.
RATHER THEY WORLD.
COMPLETE DOT INFORM A SON ON ALL
PROVISIONAL BALLOT AND ON THE
BALL ONLY.
IN OTHER WORDS SO YOU'RE JUST A
SHORT WALK BY AND TO FILL OUT A
FEW -- PIECE
OF PAPER AND THE VOTE.
WHAT IS THE PURPOSE OF A VOTER
REGISTRATION FORM AND THEN ALSO
DEADLINES THAT WE HAVE?
RATHER THEN NOT ENHANCING VOTER
PARTICIPATION THIS BEING.
OUR ONLY SERVES. TO FURTHER IN
PARO.
THE INTEGRITY OR BY WHAT
ELECTIONS SO PROCESS.
AND THE CONSEQUENT DUTY YA
UNDERMINE.
VOTER OATH TRUST A IN NOW WHAT
IT LACKS ON OUTCOMES.
THIS BILL THE HOUSE SO SEVERAL
PROBLEMS.
IT WILL DIE MAKE IT EVEN EASIER.
FOR UNSCRUPULOUS PERSONS SO TO
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF A CALIFORNIA
SO ALREADY LACKS SUSTAIN DAY
YOUR REGISTRATION SYSTEM.
UNLIKE ALTHOUGH STATES ARE
CALIFORNIA DOES NOT REQUIRE A
PERSON SO TO REGISTER ON
ELECTION DAY TO PRESENT THE
EVIDENCE SO THAT THEY ACTUALLY.
RECITE THE IN THE DISTRICT OF
THEY ARE LOOK TEMPTING. TO
FOURTEEN THE OUT THERE ARE NO
SAFEGUARDS TO PREVENT A PERSON'S
SOUL WHILE ORGANIZED SO GROUPS
ARE.
WHAT PERSON SUFFER FROM NOT
USING FORMS SO I DIDN'T IDENTITY
AND THE ADDRESSES?
FROM BOARDING UP MUCH PER TIME
SAW IN MULTIPLE JURISDICTIONS
ARE IN OUR ELECTION DAY.
ON THE ELECTION DAY [inaudible]
POLITICS.
OUR IF WE ARE WE'RE NOT INCREASE
OF WATER OF PARTICIPATION IN
IOWA ELECTION SO PROCESS.
LET'S GIVE THEM A REASON TO HAVE
A CONFIDENCE ARE IN THE
INTEGRITY OF OUR ELECTION
PROCESS.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN VOTING NO ON
THIS BILL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MS BAKER.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
MEMBERS I ALSO RISE IN
OPPOSITION RESPECTFULLY AND
REALLY BECAUSE WHATEVER
EFFICIENCIES MAYBE GANDER COST
SAVINGS FROM.
MERGING.
TO VERY IMPORTANT DOCUMENTS IN A
REGISTRAR'S OFFICE PROVISIONAL
BALLOT AND VOTER REGISTRATION IS
LOST IN THE IMPORTANCE FOR
ACCURACY IN WHAT YOU NEED TO
ACTUALLY.
I'M SCRUTINIZE ANY TO THOSE
FORMS WHICH IS VERY DIFFERENT.
A VOTER REGISTRATION CARD THE
ANALYSIS AT A REGISTRAR NEEDS TO
GO THROUGH AND THEIR STAFF
[inaudible]
CAREFULLY.
IS IS THIS VOTER A RESIDENT IN
THIS DISTRICT DO THEY HAVE THE
RIGHT TO VOTE AND TO SCRUTINIZE
HOWEVER IF THEY HAVE PROVIDED
THE INFORMATION NECESSARY TO
ENSURE THAT THEY ARE ALLOWED TO
VOTE.
A PROVISIONAL BALLOT IS TOTALLY
DIFFERENT IN THE ENVELOPE ON A
PROVISIONAL BALLOT HIS SOLE
PURPOSE IS TO MAKE SURE THAT
THERE IS A MATCHING SIGNATURE ON
THE VOTER REGISTRATION CARD
SEPARATELY FILED FROM THE
PROVISIONAL BALLOT. TO ENSURE
THAT THAT VOTER IS WHO THEY SAY
THEY ARE AND THAT THEY ARE ABLE --
TO EXERCISE THEIR CONSTITUTIONAL
RIGHT TO VOTE AND TO MAKE SURE
THERE ISN'T A DOUBLE VOTE.
PURPOSE OF A PROVISIONAL BALLOT
IS BECAUSE THERE'S SOMETHING NOT
QUITE RIGHT IN THE RECORDS OF
THE VOTING PROCESS AND WE AS A
COUNTRY DECIDED CORRECTLY SO TO
MAKE SURE THAT THAT IS NOT A
BARRIER TO SOMEONE WHO'S.
ENTITLED TO VOTE AND
LEGITIMATELY CAN THOUGH CAN DO
IT THAT'S WHAT PROVISIONAL
BALLOTS ARE FOR DAEGU THROUGH A
VERY DIFFERENT LEVEL OF SCRUTINY
IN THE REGISTRAR'S OFFICE AND
RIGHTLY SO WE NEED TO KEEP THESE.
TWO OF FORMS AND PROCESSES
TOTALLY SEPARATE.
AND IN THE FINAL POINT IS
THERE'S ERROR.
THERE'S AIR ALL THE TIMES IN
REGISTRAR'S OFFICE NOT
NECESSARILY FRAUD BUT ERROR THAT
HAPPENS AND REMOVING THE ABILITY
TO HAVE TWO SEPARATE LEVELS OF
SCRUTINY ON WHETHER VOTER
REGISTRATION IS LEGITIMATE.
OR PROVISIONAL VOTE CAST IS
LEGITIMATE COMBINING THEM
TOGETHER INCREASES THE
LIKELIHOOD OF ERROR.
R. VOTE IS TO SACROSANCT. TO
LOOK FOR AN ADMINISTRATIVE ISSUE
THAT WILL ACTUALLY MAKE IT WORSE
TO HAVE ACCURATE ELECTIONS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A NO VOTE.
AND AND KEEP IN MIND MEMBERS WE
ARE AT A TIME WHEN WE ARE TRYING
TO MAKE IT EASIER FOR REGISTRARS
WITH TECHNOLOGY TO ENSURE THAT
VOTERS ARE NOT REGISTERED IN
MORE THAN ONE PLACE.
AND VOTING PURPOSEFULLY OR
ACCIDENTALLY MORE THAN ONCE.
COMBINING THE AT THE VOTER
REGISTRATION CARD WITH THE
PROVISIONAL CARD WILL MAKE THAT
WORSE AND TAKE US BACKWARDS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A NO VOTE
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MS BAKER.
SEEING NO ADDITIONAL.
SKY XIN OUR DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
MISTER BERMAN YOU MAY CLOSE
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND I
DON'T THINK MY COLLEAGUES FOR
THAT VERY ROBUST.
A DISCUSSION I WANT TO REITERATE
THAT THIS BILL DOES NOT CHANGE
SAME DAY VOTER REGISTRATION THAT
SOMETHING THAT ALREADY EXISTS IN
CALIFORNIA AND IS FRANKLY A
TOTALLY IN A DIFFERENT POLICY
DISCUSS IN.
ALL S. B. ELEVEN SEVENTY ONE
DOES IS TAKE TWO FORMS AND MERGE
INTO ONE SINGLE FORM IT'S
SUPPORTED BY THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF CLERKS AND
ELECTIONS OFFICIALS WHO ARE NOT.
IN THE BUSINESS OF TRYING TO
INCREASE CONFUSION OR INCREASE
VOTER FRAUD --
I DON'T THINK THAT SUPPORT
SOMETHING THAT MIGHT --
CREATE UNCERTAINTY IN OUR VOTING
PROCESS THAT'S NOT WHAT THEY DO
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
ON SB ELEVEN SEVENTY ONE THANK
YOU.
THEY MISS BERMAN WITHOUT CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS
VOTE.
THESE ARE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTED IS OUT OF THE ALL MEMBERS
VOTED AS ARE THOSE [inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ROLE TALENTED BUT EYES.
FORTY THREE KNOWS.
TWENTY TWO THAT MEASURE PASSES
[inaudible]
FILE ITEMS [inaudible] SEVENTY
THREE THROUGH [inaudible] NINETY
FOUR PASS RETAIN
.
MEMBERS WE ARE AWAITING ACTIONS.
IN THE OTHER HOUSE.
IN THE MEANTIME MR GIBSON I
BELIEVE YOU HAVE AN ANNOUNCEMENT.
FOR THE BODY MISTER GIBSON YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED FOR ANNOUNCEMENT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS MEMBERS I WANT TO INVITE
EACH MEMBER TO JOIN THE BOW TIE
CAUCUS --
THIS MONDAY JULY THE SECOND TO
WEAR YOUR BOW TIES --
WE'RE ENCOURAGING STAFF --
AS WELL AS MEMBERS OF THE NEED
TO BOW TIE PLEASE COME AND SEE
ME OR SEE IT MEMBERS THE BOW TIE
CAUCUS.
ON MONDAY JULY THE SECOND WILL
BE WEAR BOW TIES AND WILL TAKE A
PHOTOGRAPH UPON ADJOURNMENTS A
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THAT IS NOT DEBATABLE THANK
INITIATIVES.
AND MEMBERS SANDERS STAND THAT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MATTHEW HARPER
CELEBRATED A BIRTHDAY YESTERDAY.
HAPPY BIRTHDAY MISTER HARD
TWENTY FOUR YEARS NOW
[inaudible]
MR [inaudible]
CALLED AROUND.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE SIXTY
THREE ANDERSON THE ROLE SEVENTY
SEVEN TO ALLOW ASSEMBLY MEMBER
TEAM TO TAKE UP.
AB EIGHTEEN THIRTY EIGHT BUT
BUDGET COMMITTEE WITHOUT
REFERENCE TO FILE FOR THE
PURPOSE OF CONCURRENCE THE
SENATE AMENDMENTS.
AND MISS WALDRON UP WE OPPOSE
THAT MOTION AND ASK FOR ROLL
CALL.
MISS WALDRON IS WITHHOLDING.
MISTER CALDERON MOVES AND MISTER
BONTA SECONDS ON THE RULES
SUSPENSION MEMBERS THIS IS A
PROCEDURAL VOTE.
THE CLERK WELL OPEN THE ROLE
MISTER CALDERON IS ASKING FOR AN
AYE VOTE AND MISS WALDRON IS
ASKING FOR A NO VOTE.
THIS IS A RULE SUSPENSION
PROCEDURAL VOTE MISTER CALDERON
IS ASKING FOR AN I. AND MISS
WALDRON AND NOW.
TAKES [inaudible]
FORTY ONE CLARK WELL.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED WISHED ABOUT
THIS IS PROCEDURAL [inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE YOUR ROLL.
TIDE BUT ICE FORTY NINE KNOWS.
EIGHTEEN THE RULES ARE SUSPENDED
.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO BE
TAKING UP AB.
EIGHTEEN THIRTY EIGHT WITHOUT
REFERENCE TO FILE.
MR TING YOU MAY OPEN.
I'M SORRY KERKORIAN.
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTEEN THIRTY
EIGHT BY THE COMMITTEE ON BUDGET
NOT RELATED TAXATION OF MAKING
AN APPROPRIATION AFFORD TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY ABILITY TO
THE BUDGET.
NOW YOU MAY OPEN MISTER TING
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
TO PRESENT AB. EIGHTEEN THIRTY
EIGHT THE REASON THAT WE ARE
PRESENTE EIGHTEEN THIRTY EIGHT
TODAY.
IT BECAUSE THERE WAS A BALLOT
MEASURE THAT WAS COLLECTING
SIGNATURES AND HAD ENOUGH
SIGNATURES TO GET ON THE BALLOT.
I JUST WANT TO SET SOME CONTEXT
REGARDING WHAT THAT BALLOT
MEASURE
WOULD HAVE DONE.
THE BALLOT MEASURE WOULD HAVE
REQUIRED ANY INCREASE IN LOCAL
TAXES TO BE APPROVED BY A TWO
THIRDS VOTE THAT MEANS
[inaudible]
ANYONE. TWO IT WOULD REQUIRE THE
LAW SPECIFY HOW TAX REVENUE CAN
BE SPENT.
IN THREE WOULD RECLASSIFY SOME
CHARGES CURRENTLY CLASSIFIED AS
FEES AS TAXES.
AND INITIATIVE WOULD HAVE BEEN
RETROACTIVE. TO PLAY A TAXES
PASSED AFTER JANUARY FIRST
[inaudible] TWENTY EIGHTEEN SO
FOR EXAMPLE IN MY CITY AND
COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO WE
PASSED.
TO TAXES.
LAST JUNE OR THIS JUNE. ONE WAS
THE PROPOSITION G. WHERE WE
RAISE A HUNDRED AND WILL BE
REYES FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
ANNUALLY. TO BE GIVEN TO
TEACHERS FOR SALARIES BECAUSE WE
FACE A TEACHING CRISIS NEVER IN
OUR PLEASE KEEP YOUR
CONVERSATIONS TO A MINIMUM.
MISTER TING YOU MAY PROCEED.
THANK YOU BUT SPEAKER WE ALSO
PASSED PROPOSITION SEE WHICH
RAISES A HUNDRED AND FORTY SIX
MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY. 85% OF
THAT FOR CHILDCARE AND 15% OF
OUR FOR GENERAL.
CITY SERVICES.
SO WE ARE.
PRESENTED WITH THIS QUANDARY
[inaudible]
ALL OF DOING SOMETHING THAT WILL
SAVE THE GREATER GOOD IN SAVE
OUR CITIES AND MANY OF THE
CRITICAL CITY SERVICES THAT ARE
RESIDENTS RELY ON EVERY DAY. TO
IN ORDER TO PASS THIS MEASURE.
THAT I PRESENT TO YOU NOW.
AB IF YOU THIRTY A PROHIBITS
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS WERE CHARGING
TAXES [inaudible]
A GROCER'S.
A PROHIBITION EXCLUDES EXISTING
LOCAL MEASURES THAT WERE IN
PLACE BEFORE THIS YEAR.
AND ALSO DOES NOT APPLY TO
CIGARETTES ALCOHOL OR CANNABIS
PRODUCTS.
SO FOR EXAMPLE THE SODA TAXES
THAT WERE PASSED.
EARLIER IN ALBANY BERKELEY OPEN
IN MY JURISDICTION SAN FRANCISCO
WILL BE ABLE TO REMAIN.
THE BILL WOULD SUNSET ON JANUARY
FIRST [inaudible] TWENTY THIRTY
ONE AGAIN ALL THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT [inaudible]
WE TRADITIONALLY.
HAVE NOT WANTED TO DO.
WE AS LEGISLATORS ARE HAVING TO
MAKE A VERY VERY TOUGH CHOICES
TODAY.
AND I AM PRESENTING THIS BILL.
IN HOPES THAT THE GREATER GOOD
WILL PREVAIL.
SO THAT OUR CITIES COULD
CONTINUE TO BRING TO THE VOTERS
[inaudible]
CRITICAL MEASURES TO FUND CITY
SERVICES SUCH AS PUBLIC SAFETY
[inaudible]
EDUCATION CHILDCARE PUBLIC WORKS
PARKS LIBRARIES AND THE LIST
GOES ON IN ORDER TO MOVE THIS
MEASURE FORWARD WE DO HAVE TO
TAKE -- WE
HAD YOU HAVE TO PASS AB EIGHTEEN
THIRTY EIGHT DID THAT.
SO WITHOUT I RESPECTFULLY ASK DR
VOTE ON A. B..
EIGHTEEN THIRTY THEY WERE
STAYING MISTER BLOOM YOUR
RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
SO I WANT TO START BY THANKING
YOU FOR YOUR BIRTHDAY WISHES LE --
LAST WEEK.
YOU KNOW THE THE OLDER I GET YOU
YOU HAVE A TENDENCY TO THINK
YOU'VE SEEN EVERYTHING.
AND THEN SOMETHING LIKE THIS
COMES ALONG [inaudible]
TODAY.
WE FACED A HOBSON'S CHOICE AS
WERE ABOUT TO VOTE TO PROTECT
OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS FROM AN
INSIDIOUS ATTACK.
ON DEMOCRACY AND IN DOING SO.
WE'RE GONNA RESTRICT THEIR
ABILITY THEIR VERY ABILITY TO
ACT ON BEHALF OF THEIR RESIDENTS
[inaudible]
IT'S OUTRAGEOUS.
TODAY'S ONE OF THOSE DAYS WHEN I
FIND IT --
THAT I HAVE TO HOLD MY NOSE AND
CHOOSE THE LESSER OF TWO EVILS
BUT WHAT ON EARTH HAS HAPPENED
HERE.
IT'S REALLY QUITE SIMPLE.
TODAY ANYONE WITH A HAREBRAINED
IDEA AND DEEP POCKETS CAN BUY A
PLACE ON OUR BALLOT AND SUBVERT
THE INITIATIVE PROCESS AND IF I
SOUND LIKE I'M FRUSTRATED
ANGERED AND DISGUSTED
[inaudible]
I AM.
FRUSTRATED THAT ONE INDUSTRY IS.
CLOSING A PATHWAY TO HELP
RESOLVE THE PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS.
I AM ANGERED THAT WERE CASTING A
VOTE TO PROHIBIT [inaudible]
PROHIBIT.
TOOL THAT LOCAL COMMUNITIES
THOSE COMMUNITIES THAT WE
PROFESS TO DEFEND HERE.
THAT THEY CAN USE TO ADDRESS
TYPE BEAT US ONE OF THE BIGGEST
AND FASTEST GROWING HEALTH
CRISES IN OUR NATION.
AS WELL AS THE ISSUE OF PLASTIC
POLLUTION ONE OF THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT ENVIRONMENTAL
DISASTERS FACING THE WORLD.
ARE TELLING OUR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES IT JUST CAN'T DO IT.
AND I'M DISGUSTED THAT ONE
INDUSTRY IS WILLING TO
PRIORITIZE THEIR PRODUCT AND
THEIR PROFITS.
OVER NOT ONLY CALIFORNIA'S NEEDS
BUT THE WORLD'S PUBLIC AND
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH.
TODAY'S DEBATE WILL CERTAINLY
RAISE CONCERNS ABOUT OUR
INITIATIVE PROCESS WHICH IS
BEING DISTORTED AND MANIPULATED.
BY MONEYED CORPORATE INTERESTS.
EXACTLY WHAT'S HAPPENING HERE
JUST LOOK AT WHERE THE MONEY'S
COMING FROM AND HOW IT'S BEEN
SPENT.
BUT WE CAN'T LOSE SIGHT OF THE
MAIN ISSUE HERE TODAY
CALIFORNIAN THE UNITED STATES
ARE FACING A GROWING HEALTH
CRISIS INVOLVING OBESITY
DIABETES AND HEART DISEASE.
AND WE KNOW THAT SUGARY DRINKS
ARE A MAJOR CONTRIBUTOR TO THIS
EPIDEMIC THERE'S LOTS THAT WE
CAN BE DISCUSSING ABOUT THIS BUT
OUR LOCAL COMMUNITIES ARE GOING
TO BE ALLOWED. TO DO WHAT THEY
NEED TO DO.
DIE BE THIS IS NOW THE SEVENTH
LARGEST CAUSE OF DEATH IN THE
NATION.
AND ONE IN THREE CHILDREN BORN
AFTER.
TWO THOUSAND MANY OF YOU HAVE
YOUNG CHILDREN.
THINK ABOUT THIS.
AND HALF OF ALL AFRICAN AMERICAN
AND HISPANIC CHILDREN WILL
DEVELOP TYPE TWO DIABETES.
PREVENTABLE TYPE TWO DIABETES
CONTRARY TO WHAT INDUSTRY
REPRESENTATIVES WILL SAY THE
OVERWHELMING VIEW OF HEALTH
EXPERTS ACROSS THE COUNTRY IS
THAT THE SINGLE MOST SIGNIFICANT
CONTRIBUTOR. TO OBESITY AND
DIABETES IS OVER CONSUMPTION OF
SUGAR PARTICULARLY IN BEVERAGES
SINCE NINETEEN SEVENTY SEVEN
AMERICANS HAVE DOUBLED THEIR
INTAKE OF SUGAR AND SUGAR
SWEETENED BEVERAGES.
EVERYTHING FROM SODAS SWEDEN
TEASE SPORTS DRINKS FLUTE FRUIT
FLAVORED DRINKS.
THEY ACCOUNT FOR A 43% ARE THAT
THEY ACCOUNT 4403% OF THAT
INCREASE.
THE AVERAGE AMERICAN NOW DRINKS
MORE THAN FORTY FIVE GALLONS OF
SUGAR SWEETENED BEVERAGES PER
YEAR AND OBESITY AND DIABETES
ARE COSTING THE STATE.
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS EVERY YEAR
IN HOSPITALIZATION AND MEDICARE
COSTS THAT COULD HAVE BEEN
PREVENTED IF ONLY THERE WAS
MONEY FOR PREVENTION.
IN FACT ONE ESTIMATE HAS IT THAT
75% OF EVERY HEALTHCARE DOLLAR
GOES TO MAINTENANCE OR TREATMENT
OF CHRONIC METABOLIC DISEASE
[inaudible]
SEVENTY FIVE SENT.
CALIFORNIANS ARE LOSING THEIR
LIVES AND THEIR LIMBS.
IN IN TWENTY TEN ALONE ABOUT
SEVENTY THREE THOUSAND NON FROM
ADDICT LOWER LIMB AMPUTATIONS.
SEVENTY THREE THOUSAND WERE
PERFORMED IN ADULTS TWENTY YEARS
OR OLDER WITH DIAGNOSED DIABETES.
DOCTORS ARE REPORTING STROKES IN
EIGHT YEAR OLDS HEART ATTACKS
AND TEN YEAR OLDS.
AND DIO'S FOR KIT FOR KIDNEY
FAILURE IN THIRTY YEAR OLDS.
STATEWIDE FROM TWENTY TEN TO
TWENTY SEVENTEEN THAT WAS A 31%
INCREASE IN THESE AMPUTATIONS.
SINCE TWENTY TOWN FOLKS.
UNFORTUNATELY IS A STATE WE HAVE
NOT DONE ENOUGH TO TAKE ON THIS
PROBLEM AND IN OUR ABSENCE
CITIES WERE DOING SO.
LOCAL GOVERNMENT IS THE
INCUBATOR FOR MANY OF OUR MOST
PRESSING ISSUES WE LOOK TO OUR
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO BE BOLD
CREATIVE AND TO DEVELOP POLICY
SOLUTIONS.
MANY OF WHICH WE THEN IMPLEMENT
STATEWIDE THIRTY SECOND ON THE
ISSUE OF DIABETES AND OBESITY
THEY'VE DONE JUST THAT.
AND IT'S WORKED NOW THE
INDUSTRY'S PANICKED OVERBEARING
RESPONSE TO THESE LOCAL EFFORTS
TELLS US ALL WE NEED TO KNOW
ABOUT THE SEVERITY OF THIS
CRISIS.
AND THE EFFICACY OF THE
GRASSROOTS MOVEMENT THAT HAVE
RISEN UP TO TAKE IT ON BUT IT
DOESN'T STRIP OUR ABILITY TO ACT.
NOW THE RESPONSIBILITY IS PLEASE
GLEE ON US NOW MORE THAN EVER
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA WILL
LOOK TO US TO FIX THIS
COMPLETELY PREVENTABLE PROBLEM
AND REVERSED THIS HORRIBLE
EPIDEMIC.
THAT IS TAKING LIVES AND
NEEDLESSLY RIPPING FAMILIES AND
COMMUNITIES PART TIME IS UP MR
BLOOM.
TODAY ARE RELUCTANTLY VOTE ON
THIS BILL FOR THE GREATER GOOD
AND ASK FOR YOUR I'VE OF DOCTOR
EGGMAN.
YOUR RECOGNIZE THANK YOUR
SPEAKER IT MEMBERS I ALSO RISE
TO VOICE MY MY FRUSTRATION WITH
THIS PROCESS AND I KNOW THAT I
HAVE A LARGE CONTINGENT OF YOUNG
PEOPLE FROM STOCKTON WHO --
WERE ORGANIZING TO PUT A SUGAR
TAX ON OUR BALLOT AND HAVE COME
UP TODAY TO VOICE THEIR
FRUSTRATION TO THE COMMITTEE WHO
MET BEFORE.
SO I WOULD SAY TO THEM I WOULD
SAY TO EVERYBODY.
THAT SOMETIMES YOU HAVE TO LOOK
AT THE THE LONG GAME AND WHILE
IT IS A VERY CLEAR EXAMPLE TODAY
WE SEE OF WHAT DEEP POCKETS CAN
DO TO OUR DEMOCRACY.
AND WE SEE TODAY THAT WE ARE
TAKING A PAUSE IN THE BATTLE
AGAINST OBESITY.
BUT IT'S JUST A PAUSE.
AND THE FIGHT GOES ON AND THE
MORE THAT WE HEAR THE YOUNG
PEOPLE RAISE THEIR VOICES.
IS TODAY WHAT WE'RE SAYING IS A
VERY TOP HEAVY DOWN A CORPORATE.
PUSH DOWN ON DEMOCRACY.
BUT FOR EVERY ACTION THERE IS A
REACTION.
AND SO I ENCOURAGE THE YOUNG
PEOPLE AND ACTIVISTS AROUND AS
WE CONTINUE THIS FIGHT FOR
PUBLIC HEALTH AND AGAINST TO BE
SEATED TO CONTINUE TO RAISE YOUR
VOICES AND TO ORGANIZE AND TO
LET THIS BE AN EXAMPLE TO YOU.
OF ONE BUT WHEN BLOCKADES
PRESENT THEMSELVES WE NEED TO
FIND ANOTHER WAY AROUND.
SO THE FIGHT CONTINUES.
BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT THE ABILITY.
TO RAISE TAXES AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS IS WHAT THE CITY OF
STOCKTON HAS JUST COME OUT OF
BANKRUPTCY AND LAST YEAR.
THE CITIZENS VOTED A TAX UPON
THEMSELVES TO INCREASE THE
POLICE DEPARTMENT AND TO
INCREASE.
PARKS.
NOW WE HAVE LIBRARIES OPEN EVERY
DAY OF THE WEEK WOULDN'T HAVE
THAT LAST YEAR.
WE NOW HAVE LIBRARIES OPEN EVERY
DAY OF THE WEEK THAT IS A
WONDERFUL THING.
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE ABLE TO DO
WOULDN'T LOCAL PEOPLE DECIDE TO
TAX THEMSELVES THAT IS WHY WE
DON'T WANT TO TAKE THAT.
AND THAT ABILITY AWAY FROM THEM.
SO AGAIN WHILE WE ARE TAKING A
PAUSE IN THE BATTLE.
WHAT WE DO IS RE GROUP?
AND WE GO FORWARD.
SO ALSO RELUCTANTLY BE
SUPPORTING THISTODAY I
ENCOURAGE ALL THE YOUNG PEOPLE
WHO CAME FROM STOCKTON AND ALL
AROUND TO LET THIS BE AN EXAMPLE.
A WHAT IT LOOKS LIKE CORPORATE
MONEY LOOKS LIKE [inaudible]
AND STRATEGIZE.
ABOUT THE REACTION.
THANK YOU DOCTOR EGGMAN MISTER
COOLEY.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
CALLING SOMEONE A RISE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE AND I
WANNA.
OFFER A LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT
TAKE ON WHY I THINK THIS IS THE
RIGHT VOTE TO CAST --
YESTERDAY I THINK OUR NATION
TOOK A COLLECTIVE [inaudible]
BREATH.
AS ANTHONY KENNEDY.
ANNOUNCED HE WOULD BE RETIRING
AT THE END OF THIS TERM.
US SUPREME COURT JUSTICE ANTHONY
KENNEDY.
AND IT BROUGHT TO MIND
[inaudible]
THAT ACTOR [inaudible]
REMARKABLY. FIFTEEN YEARS AGO
THIS MONTH.
I RECEIVED A NOTE.
FROM THE PRIVATE CHAMBERS OF U.
S. SUPREME COURT JUSTICE DANTE
KINNITTY.
CAME TO MY HOME KENNETH WILLIAM
COOLEY COOPER RIVER COURT.
RANCHO CORDOVA.
AND I OPEN THAT NOTE AND IT WAS
A LETTER OF COMMENDATION
CONGRATULATIONS TO ME.
AND MY FUTURE COLLEAGUES.
AS WE WERE GOING TO ESTABLISH ON
JULY FIRST.
THE BRAND NEW CITY OF RANCHO
CORDOVA.
IN SACRAMENTO COUNTY WHICH WAS
THE HOME.
OF TONY KENNEDY.
AND THE WORST CEASE EXTENDED TO
ME IN THAT LETTER.
WE'RE VERY RELEVANT TO A NEW
CITY BUT I THINK THERE ARE ALSO
RELEVANT TO WHY.
A VOTE LIKE THIS COMES ALONG.
WHY ALREADY ON THIS FLOOR WE'VE
HEARD?
A RELUCTANCE TO CAST THIS VOTE.
A VOTE LIKE THIS IS SEEN AS A
HOBSON'S CHOICE.
CONCERNS THAT CIRCUMSTANCES
AROUND US THAT IMPERIL DEMOCRACY.
AND THAT THERE IS A NEED TO KEEP
PEOPLE ENGAGED IN OUR DEMOCRACY
AND FIGHTING ON IMPORTANT ISSUES.
AND NOT TO LOSE HOPE WHEN.
ISSUES LIKE THIS ARISE.
AND THAT THE STATEMENTS MADE BY
TONY KENNEDY TO ME. FIFTEEN
YEARS AGO WHEN I WAS NOT YET
ELECTED OFFICIALS.
PERMISSION TO READ.
WITHOUT OBJECTION.
CONGRATULATIONS TO YOU.
AND ALL OF YOUR COLLEAGUES. FOR
WORKING TO REINVIGORATE THE
PRINCIPLE.
A PARTICIPATORY DEMOCRACY.
HE WENT ON TO SAY SELF
GOVERNMENT MUST NOT BE AN
ABSTRACT IDEAL.
WHAT BUT MUST BE A REALITY?
AND HE SAID WE MUST BE UNCEASING
AND OUR EFFORTS. TO MAKE IT MORE
EFFECTIVE AND RESPECTED BY OUR
PEOPLE.
I ACTUALLY VIEW THIS VOTE.
AS IT RELATES TO A SPECIFIC AREA
SOFT DRINKS OBESITY THESE
UNDERLYING ISSUES.
BUT WE SEE PEOPLE TAKING THE
INVESTOR PROCESS IN A WAY THE
HIRAM JOHNSON NEVER SOUGHT.
MANIPULATE AND USE IT TO FORCE
ISSUES.
BELIEVING THAT BIG MONEY SPENT
ON BALLOTS CAN CAN RESHAPE.
OUTCOMES OF ISSUES OF GREAT
CONSEQUENCE.
AND THIS BECOMES A MOMENT WHEN
WE ON THIS FLOOR.
GRAPPLE WITH OUR PLACE TO SORT
OF BE THE CARE [inaudible]
CARE.
CARETAKERS AND STEWARDS OF
DEMOCRACY TRYING TO MAKE SURE
OUR DEMOCRATIC PROCESSES.
PORT PARTICIPATORY DEMOCRACY AT
EVERY LEVEL --
ARE IN FACT REAL A REALITY NOT.
RUN ROUGHSHOD OVER --
BY MONEYED INTERESTS.
AND SO I I RISE --
ON THE COUNCIL OF SUPREME COURT
JUSTICE TONY KENNEDY EXPRESSED
REPRODUCTIVE YEARS AGO.
THAT THERE IS A TIME WHEN YOU
HAVE TO TAKE A STAND.
FOR DEMOCRACY AND A DEMOCRATIC
INSTITUTIONS AND AIR TONIGHT
VOTE.
DOCTOR WOULD YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS THE I RISE TODAY TO AND
I'M GONNA CAST A VOTE TODAY THAT
I NEVER EVER EXPECTED I'D HAVE
TO CAST.
YEAH I CAME HERE TO CONDUCT
MENDOZA HEALTH CARE PROVIDER TO
HELP IMPROVE THE HEALTH OF
PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA.
AND I NEVER EXPECTED TO HAVE TO
MAKE A CHOICE LIKE THIS.
ATTACK THE ABILITY OF OUR CITIES
TO TO RAISE MONEY FOR
INFRASTRUCTURE PUBLIC SAFETY.
AS A TRADE OFF. TO AN INDUSTRY.
THEY WANT TO PERPETUATE
[inaudible]
OBESITY [inaudible]
DENTAL DECAY [inaudible]
DIABETES.
THIS IS OUR THEIR WORDS I HAVE
SEEN IN THE PRESS TO DESCRIBE
THIS [inaudible]
STORES XIN.
DISTORTION IS DEFINED AS THE
PRACTICE OF ATTAINING SOMETHING.
THROUGH FORCE OR THREATS.
THAT'S WHAT'S HAPPENING THIS
WEEK.
AND THE BAD ACTORS ARE THE SODA
INDUSTRY.
AND THE WAY THEY'RE DOING THIS
IS ABSOLUTELY OUTRAGEOUS.
WHEN I WAS IN THE CITY COUNCIL
THE CITY OF HEALDSBURG?
AS THE MAYOR WE WERE THE FIRST
CITY IN THE STATE TO TRY TO
RAISE THE SMOKING AGE.
TO TWENTY ONE TECH TO HELP
PEOPLE FOR PEOPLE.
WE FOUND OUT.
THAT WE COULDN'T DO THAT
[inaudible]
BECAUSE STATE LAW PREEMPTED US
FROM DOING THAT.
NOW LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA
JURISDICTIONS THROUGHOUT THE
UNITED STATES HAVE BEEN RAISING
MONEY.
AND FIGHTING FIRST FOR SO TAXES.
IN TWO THOUSAND AND FOURTEEN IT
STARTED TO WORK.
AND GUESS WHAT.
ASSUMPTION IS GOING DOWN.
AND IT'S TERRIFIED THE INDUSTRY.
SO WHAT THIS MEASURE DIES.
IS IT BRINGS FULL CIRCLE IT
BRAINS THAT ISSUE BACK TO THIS
BODY TAKES IT OUT OF THE HANDS
THE LOCALS.
WE'RE CREATING THE NEW TOBACCO
HERE TODAY.
IT'S CALLED THE SODA INDUSTRY.
EVERYTHING'S GONNA HAVE TO GO TO
HEAR SO NOT ONLY ARE THEY GOING
TO CONTINUE TO MAKE OUTRAGEOUS
PROFITS BECAUSE IT'S A VERY
PROFITABLE INDUSTRY.
BUT THERE GONNA BE OTHER
CONCENTRATE ALL THEIR RESOURCES
ON THIS BODY AND THE SENATE AND
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE TO PREVENT
US.
FROM DOING WHAT'S RIGHT.
PEOPLE COME TO US ALL THE TIME
TO TALK ABOUT THE RISING COST OF
HEALTHCARE [inaudible]
AND YET.
WE'RE PERPETUATING THAT.
WE CAN'T GET THE MONEY WE NEED.
THROUGH ART PROCESS. TO GIVE
EDUCATION ENOUGH EDUCATION ON
DIABETES PREVENTION.
BUT YET WE SPEND BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS ON TREATMENT. FOR
DIABETES AND OBESITY AND HEART
DISEASE.
THE HYPOCRISY OF THIS
[inaudible]
ABSOLUTELY APPALLING.
THEY MAY WIN THE BATTLE TODAY
BUT THEY WILL NOT WIN THE WAR.
CAREFUL WHAT YOU WISH FOR YOU
WILL GALVANIZE PEOPLE LIKE THOSE
TWENTY FIVE STUDENTS FROM
STOCKTON TO CAME IN HERE TODAY
TO SPEAK THEIR MIND.
WE WILL WIN THE WAR AND WE WILL
BE ABLE TO PROTECT PEOPLE FROM
THERE.
AND THEN PROTECT THEIR HEALTH
AND REDUCE THE COST TO THE STATE
[inaudible] FOR THIS.
I CHALLENGE THE SODA INDUSTRY
WHO HAS COMPILED MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS INTO THIS CAMPAIGN
INITIATIVE COUNT.
GIVE IT BACK A COMMUNITIES.
REPUBLIC HEALTH PROGRAMS.
DON'T IT'S TO GET BACK IN YOUR
POCKETS AND DON'T GIVE IT BACK
TO YOUR SHAREHOLDERS GIVE IT
BACK TO COMMUNITIES.
IS YOU'RE GONNA USE THAT MONEY
TO TRY TO DISENFRANCHISE PEOPLE.
ALTHOUGH FOR THIS TODAY VERY
VERY REGRETFULLY THIS IS A
REALLY SAD DAY FOR ME PERSONALLY.
BUT I WILL NOT QUIT FIGHTING.
THEY THAT WOULD.
MISTER GALLAGHER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS --
YOU KNOW I AGREE WITH WHAT MANY
MY COLLEAGUES HAVE SAID I THINK
THIS PROCESS STAKES.
I THINK THIS PROCESS TAKES THE
POWER OUT OF THE HANDS OF THE
LEGISLATURE.
I THINK IT KEEPS US FROM BEING
ABLE TO DO OUR JOB THE JOB THAT.
WE WERE ELECTED TO DO. TO VET
BILL IDEA IS TO TAKE THEM TO THE
COMMITTEE PROCESS TO HAVE PUBLIC
INPUT.
AND TO ALL ULTIMATELY HOPEFULLY
AT THE END OF THAT PROCESS HAVE
GOOD PUBLIC POLICY THAT'S
ESTABLISH. FOR THIS STATE.
WHAT I AM KIND OF BEWILDERED BY
IS?
THIS KIND OF THAT WEEK THAT WE
DON'T HAVE ANYTHING THAT WE CAN
DO ABOUT IT THERE'S ACTUALLY
SOMETHING WE CAN DO ABOUT IT WE
CAN NOT VOTE FOR THIS.
BILL.
WE CANNOT GO ALONG WITH THIS
DEAL.
AND FIRST JUST A LITTLE BIT OF
HISTORY.
THIS IS NOT THE FIRST TIME THIS
HAS HAPPENED FOLKS WE ALL KNOW
THAT.
WE WERE ALL MANY OF US WERE HERE
LAST YEAR LAST TERM.
WHEN SEIU ESTABLISH THE
PRECEDENT OF DOING THIS?
BY GETTING OF A MEASURE
QUALIFIED ON THE BALLOT AND THEN
STRIKING A DEAL.
AND BECAUSE YOU LIKE THE RESULT
YOU WANT ALONG WITH IT.
ANY ALLOWED. TO GO FOR THE
FIFTEEN DOLLAR MINIMUM WAGE
INCREASE.
YOU ALLOW THEM TO DO THAT NOW
OTHER SPECIAL INTERESTS JUST
LIKE THEM.
ARE DOING THE SAME THING.
IF YOU WANNA STOP THAT PRECEDENT.
THERE'S SOMETHING YOU CAN DO
ABOUT IT.
WE'RE ALL SITTING HERE RIGHT NOW.
WE HAVE A VOTE.
WE COULD DECIDE TO VOTE NO OR
YOU CAN DECIDE NOT TO VOTE AT
ALL.
IT SAY AND THAT WILL DEMAND THAT
PEOPLE GO.
BACK TO THE PROCESS THAT WE ALL.
THERE ARE CONSTITUENTS I THINK
ONE US TO TO ABIDE BY AND THAT
WE ALL WANT TO DO WE WANT TO
HAVE GOOD POLICY ONE HAVE A
DEBATE IT WE WILL.
DISCUSS WE WANT TO HAVE IT
VETTED.
IT SHOULDN'T BE THAT WE HAVE THE
THREAT OF AN INITIATIVE IN THE
LAST.
COUPLE DAYS WE CRAFT TOGETHER
SOME LANGUAGE AND SAY OKAY GUYS
LET'S VOTE ON YOU DON'T HAVE TO
DO THAT.
BECAUSE THE GOVERNOR SAYS YOU
HAVE TO OUR BECAUSE YOU PARTY
SAYS YOU HAVE TO WE DON'T HAVE
TO DO THAT.
WE TALK A LOT THIS LEGISLATURE
ABOUT HOW WE'RE GOING TO BE
DIFFERENT.
WELL HERE'S YOUR OPPORTUNITY TO
DO IT.
IT'S NOT A HOBSON'S CHOICE BY
THE WAY EITHER IT'S NOT A
HOBSON'S CHOICE AT ALL.
ON THE ONE HAND YOU LET THE
PEOPLE DECIDE.
BY INITIATIVE THEY GET TO VOTE.
TO THEY CAN DECIDE WHAT THEY
WANT THEIR TAX THRESHOLD TO BE.
THEY CAN ALSO DECIDE WHAT KIND
OF TAXES THAT THEY WANT TO HAVE
LOCALLY.
ON THAT SIDE IS OF IS GIVING
VOTERS A VOICE GIVING THEM A
CHANCE TO WEIGH IN ON THESE
ISSUES.
ON THE OTHER SIDE IS GOING ALONG
WITH THE SPECIAL INTERESTS.
NO MATER WHAT SIDE THEY ARE NO
MATTER WHICH ONE SIP SUPPORT.
ONE OR THE OTHER WE CAN SAY NO
TO THE SPECIAL INTERESTS I KNOW
WE'RE NOT GONNA LET YOU USE THE
INITIATIVE TO SUBVERT OUR
PROCESS.
WE CAN DO SOMETHING ABOUT IT.
TODAY'S US SO PLEASE.
I KNOW THIS BOTHERS A LOT IF IT
BOTHERS YOU THEN LET'S DO
SOMETHING ABOUT IT LET'S STOP
RIGHT HERE AND WILL SEND A BIG
MESSAGE ACROSS THE STATE WERE
KNOCKING ALLOWED TO HAPPEN
ANYMORE.
AND WE'RE GONNA GO BACK TO THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS THAT WE HAVE
BEEN ELECTED [inaudible] TO
CONDUCT.
MASSEY DO THAT TODAY MEMBERS
LET'S JOIN TOGETHER LET'S SEND A
MESSAGE.
ACROSS THE STATE TO THE SPECIAL
INTERESTS DON'T GET TO DICTATE
WHAT WE DO.
THEY DON'T GET TO DICTATE.
THEY DON'T TO TAKE OF THE CHOICE
AWAY FROM THE VOTERS.
PLEASE JOIN ME TODAY AND AND
STOP IN THIS LEGISLATION THANK
YOU.
MISTER KALRA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS --
I THINK THAT ONE THING THAT.
MANY COLLEAGUES HAVE MENTIONED
IS OF THE NATIONAL PROCESS AND I
THINK THAT ALL OF US ARE GONNA.
COMMIT --
I'M CONFIDENT THE MOST BLESSED
NOT ALL OF US WILL COMMIT TO
FIXING THOSE BROKEN SYSTEM THAT
PUTS US IN THIS POSITION.
OF WE KNOW THE CAN THE
CONSUMPTION A SODA AND OTHER
SHOULD WE DRINKS DROPPED 21% AND
LOW INCOME NEIGHBORHOODS IN
BERKELEY.
A YEAR AFTER ITS PENNY BROWN'S
TAX TOOK A FACT.
NOW WE'RE STARTING TO SEE THAT.
THESE TAXES WORK.
THEY'RE ACTUALLY PRODUCING THE
RESULTS I DESIRED [inaudible]
AND JUST.
AS WE'RE STARTING TO SEE THOSE
RESULTS.
BIG SODAS GETTING SCARED.
AND NOW JOINING THE RANKS OF BIG
TOBACCO WE HAVE BIG SODA.
TRYING TO INFLUENCE THE ABILITY.
FOR COMMUNITIES TOXIC CARE FOR
THEMSELVES.
COCA COLA TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
HAD NET REVENUES OF THIRTY FIVE
POINT FOUR BILLION DOLLARS.
PEPSICO.
HAD NET REVENUES OF SIXTY THREE
BILLION [inaudible]
DOLLARS.
AT THE HEART WHAT THEY DO
ACCORDING TO PEPSICO'S
PERFORMANCE WITH PURPOSE
EMPOWERING PEOPLE AROUND THE
WORLD.
WELL I GUESS THAT DOESN'T
INCLUDE.
PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA
NEIGHBORHOODS AND COMMUNITIES
[inaudible]
AND THE SPONSOR OF THIS INITIAL
PROPERTY BUSINESS ROUNDTABLE YOU
GO. TO THEIR WEBSITE LOOK UNDER
BALLOT INITIATIVES SPACE MENTION
A COUPLE OF DON'T IMAGINE THIS
[inaudible]
ONE THEY KNOW.
WHAT IT IS THEY'RE DOING?
THE NEAR TIMES HAD A HEADLINE.
ON THIS FIASCO SAYING A NEW
INDUSTRY STRATEGY IS STUNNING
SOME LAWMAKERS.
FRANKLY DOESN'T STUNNED ME BUT
IT DOES MAKE ME STICK SICK TO MY
STOMACH.
IT DOESN'T STUN ME BECAUSE MONEY
HAS INFECTED OUR DEMOCRACY TO
THE BREAKING POINT.
SO IMPACTED THE INITIATIVE
PROCESS IS IMPACT OF THE
ELECTORAL PROCESS ISN'T IT IS
IMPACTED EVERYBODY A GOVERNMENT
IN THIS NATION.
EVEN HERE WERE WEALTHY
INDUSTRIES DICTATE FAR TOO OFTEN
INCREMENTAL INCREMENTAL CHANGE
WERE ABLE TO ACCOMPLISH OR IF
WE'RE ABLE TO PROTECT
CALIFORNIANS AT ALL [inaudible]
NOW.
I KNOW THE DETAILS THE BILLS SAY
WE THIRTEEN YEARS YOU KNOW
LITTLE SUNSET ON I TELL EVERYONE
HERE AND CERTAINLY THE YOUNG
PEOPLE UP THERE YOU DON'T HAVE
TO WAIT THIRTEEN YEARS. TO MAKE
CHANGE IN TO FIGHT BACK BECAUSE
BIG SODA.
DECLARED WAR ON THIS BODY BIG
SORT A DECLARED WAR.
ON ALL LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES
PEOPLE OF COLOR YOUNG PEOPLE
THAT CARE ABOUT THEIR
COMMUNITIES.
LET'S REMEMBER THAT.
SO THEY MAY WANT TODAY'S BATTLE
AS MY COLLEAGUE SAID.
BUT I AM COURAGE EVERYONE TO
STAND UP.
USE ANY PEACEFUL MEANS POSSIBLE
[inaudible]
INFORM BOYCOTT EDUCATE.
DO WHAT YOU HAVE TO DO.
AND DO IT WITH LOVE AND
COMPASSION YOUR HEARTS BUT WE'RE
GOING TO CONTINUE TO FIGHT EVERY
SINGLE DAY ON A FIGHT EVERY
SINGLE DAY I'M CERTAINLY HERE.
AND I'D I'M I REALLY HOPE THE
YOUNG PEOPLE LEARN SOMETHING
TODAY BUT DON'T FEEL DEJECTED.
I FEEL INSPIRED CONTINUE TO
FIGHT ON AND MARCH ON BECAUSE WE
NEED YOU.
WE REALLY NEED YOU AND SO --
I'M GRATEFUL TO MY COLLEAGUES I
HAVE SPOKEN UP.
ARE CRITICIZING THE SHAKEDOWN.
AND I REALLY REALLY KNOW THAT WE
CAN DO BETTER AS A BODY BUT MORE
IMPORTANTLY WE NEED TO STAND UP
NOT DECIDE THIS INDUSTRY BUT TO
MANY INDUSTRIES.
THAT PUSH US AROUND AND TRY TO
DICTATE WHAT WE DO IN THIS BODY.
MR MATHIS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
[inaudible]
THIS LEGISLATION I OF A GOT I
AGREE IT'S IS EXTREMELY
TROUBLING.
IT IT'S TROUBLING TO ME
[inaudible]
AS WAS SOMEBODY THAT SERVED OUR
COUNTRY TO ENSURE ALL THESE
RIGHTS.
IT BOTHERS ME AS AS A FATHER.
THE KNOW THIS ENTIRE PROCESS.
THE THE IDEA OF PUTTING A BALLOT
INITIATIVE OUT THERE.
GIVEN IT TO THE WILL OF THE
VOTERS. TO THE PEOPLE WHO ELECT
US TO BE HERE.
IN THE FIRST PLACE TO THE PEOPLE
THAT ELECT.
OUR CITY GOVERNMENTS THAT.
SOME ARE GREEN YOU KNOW WE NEED
TO PROTECT.
IN IN YOUR ABSOLUTELY RIGHT WE
NEED TO PROTECT LOCAL CONTROL WE
NEED TO PROTECT THESE THINGS.
WE NEED TO PROTECT OUR FAMILIES
OUR CHILDREN.
BUT WE ALSO NEED TO STOP.
PLAIN OF THE BLAME GAME.
WE NEED TO LOOK AT THINGS LIKE.
PERSONAL RESPONSIBILITY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY.
WE HAVE A DIABETES PROBLEM.
WE ALSO HAVE A HUGE PAIR TEAM
PROBLEM IN THE STATE.
WE'VE GOT A LOT OF THINGS GOING
ON IT SICKENS ME.
AS A PARENT.
THAT ANY OF US ARE GONNA BLAME
BIG SOLEDAD.
ON OUR KIDS GETTING DIABETES.
STEP UP AND BE A PARENT.
YOU CAN TEACH YOUR KIDS HEALTHY
HABITS.
WE USED TO TEACH HOME EC.
WE USED TO TEACH PARENTS HOW THE
PARENTS.
BUT UNFORTUNATELY.
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THE
FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY IS THE
WORLD AS WE ALL LOVE TO BRAG
[inaudible]
AND ARE.
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS OF EXTRA
TAXES THOUGH WE'VE BROUGHT IN
THIS YEAR.
THAT WE CAN'T FIGURE OUT A
BETTER PROCESS.
SO INSTEAD WE'RE GONNA BLAME BIG
INDUSTRY WE'RE GOING BLAME.
THIS WE'RE GONNA PLAY GAMES WITH
AN INITIATIVE PROCESS WE DO THE
SAME THING AS MY COLLEAGUE FROM
YUBA.
SAID S. YA YOU FIFTEEN DOLLARS
MINIMUM WAGE WE WE'VE SEEN THIS
MEMBERS.
STOP GETTING PLAYED.
WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO STOP
THE NONSENSE.
BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY WE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY IS LEGISLATURE'S IN
THE STATE THAT HAS A 24% POVERTY
RATES. TO LOOK OUT FOR OUR
PARENTS THE SAD PART IS IS WE
ARE PARENTS WORKING MULTIPLE
JOBS TO PUT FOOD ON THE TABLE
FOR THEIR KIDS.
THEY DON'T HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO STAY HOME AND PARENT THEIR
CHILDREN THEY DON'T HAVE THE
TIME TO SPEND THAT QUALITY TIME
WITH THEIR KIDS.
BECAUSE THEY'RE TOO BUSY PAYING
ALL THESE DAMN TAXES.
SO WHY ARE YOU [inaudible]
COLLEAGUES [inaudible]
MEMBERS.
FELLOW PARENTS FELLOW
LEGISLATORS.
QUIT PLAYING THE GAME.
WE HAVE THE ABILITY.
TELL THE SYSTEM IN OUR STATE WE
HAVE THE ABILITY. TO LOWER THE
COST OF LIVING.
GET OUR FAMILIES OUT OF THIS 24%
POVERTY AND GIVE THEM THE
ABILITY TO HAVE THAT QUALITY
TIME WITH THEIR CHILDREN.
AND WE HAVE THE ABILITY TO VOTE
NO ON THIS NONSENSE TODAY.
IN TURN AROUND AND MAKE A BETTER
CALIFORNIA EYES FOR NO VOTE.
THANK YOU MR MATHIS.
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS AND I THINK ALL
MY COLLEAGUES FOR STANDING UP IN
SHARING.
THEIR PERSPECTIVES IN THEIR
OPINIONS AND THEIR FRUSTRATIONS --
WITH WHAT'S GOING ON TODAY AND
AND THE POSITION THAT WE'RE ALL
IN YOU KNOW WHEN I FIRST RAN FOR
OFFICE STARTED MY CAMPAIGN WAS
TWENTY FIVE WHEN I GOT ELECTED
AT TWENTY SEVEN WHEN I GOT
ELECTED I THINK WE ALL.
GET ELECTED WITH THIS THE SAME
IDEA WE JUST WANT TO COME UP
HERE TO DO SOME GOOD. TO COME UP
HERE TO MAKE PEOPLE'S LIVES A
LITTLE BIT BETTER TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE REPRESENTING OUR
CONSTITUENTS THE WAY THAT THEY
DESERVE TO BE REPRESENTED.
A PART OF DOING THAT JOB IS
MAKING DIFFICULT DECISIONS.
AND WHAT WE'RE FACED WITH TODAY
IS A DIFFICULT DECISION
[inaudible]
AND WE CAN TALK ABOUT THE
PROCESS WE CAN TALK ABOUT
WHETHER WE LIKE IT OR NOT BUT
IT'S THE POSITION THAT WE'RE IN
BECAUSE OF THE LAWS THAT WE HAVE.
AND IT'S TRUE AND THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ANYBODY IN THIS STATE
WHETHER THEY'RE HERE OR THERE
OUT OF STATE AS LONG AS THEY
HAVE ENOUGH MONEY THEY CAN HIRE
A BUNCH OF PEOPLE TO COLLECT A
BUNCH OF SIGNATURES AND PUT
SOMETHING ON OUR BALLOT.
THAT FORCES ARE HAND AT TIMES OR
PUTS US IN A POSITION.
WELL WE HAVE TO MAKE THESE TYPES
OF CHOICES OR THEY MISINFORM THE
VOTERS TO MAKE A DECISION THAT
ULTIMATELY IS POOR FOR THEM.
WHAT WE'RE DOING HERE IS WE'RE
TRYING TO SAVE OUR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS WERE TRYING TO PUT
THEM IN A POSITION SO THAT THEY
CAN PROVIDE THE RESOURCES THAT
THEY NEED TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE?
BY THE CAN. TO SERVE THE
CONSTITUENTS THAT ELECTED THEM
TO TAKE CARE OF THEM.
BUT THE REAL PROBLEM HERE.
IS THIS INITIATIVE PROCESS AND I
THINK THAT WHAT WE'RE SEEING
HERE TODAY.
IS A WHOLE BUNCH OF MY MEMBERS
THAT ARE UPSET WITH THE POSITION
THAT WHAT THE WHAT THE SITUATION
THAT WE HAVE THAT SHOULD BE
READY TO COMMIT TO REFORMING.
THAT INITIATIVE PROCESS THAT'S
WHAT WE NEED TO COMMIT TO DO.
BECAUSE YOU KNOW WHAT YOU KNOW
WHAT THE INITIATIVE PROCESS IS
TO US AND AS LEGISLATORS IN THIS
BODY.
IT'S EVERY TIME SOMETHING GETS
PASS ON THAT BALLOT.
IT HAMSTRINGS US IN A PUTS US
INTO AN AWKWARD AND UNFORTUNATE
POSITION IMAGINE YOUR BUILDER
YOU WANT TO BUILD A HOUSE.
AND WHEN I SAY I WANT MY HOUSE
BUILT IN TWO WEEKS THIS IS WHAT
I WANT TO LOOK LIKE AND I
EXPLAINED EVERYTHING.
AND SO YOU HAD THOSE TWO WEEKS
BEFORE I LEAVE I TAKE YOUR TOOLS
ANTI ONE OF YOUR HANDS BEHIND
YOUR BACK.
STILL HAVE THE SAME TIMELINE NOW
YOU DON'T HAVE YOUR TOOLS THE
ONLY HAVE ONE HAND TO DO IT
THAT'S THE INITIATIVE PROCESS IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
THAT'S WHAT IT MEANS OF THIS
LEGISLATURE WE ARE BEING.
HAMSTRING FROM BEING ABLE TO DO
OUR JOB BY THIS INITIATIVE
PROCESS AND IT SHOULD BE A
LESSON TO EVERYBODY THAT GETS
APPROACHED BY SOMEONE TO SIGN AN
INITIATIVE.
PAYING ATTENTION TO WHAT YOU'RE
CITING.
READ WHAT YOU'RE SIGNING DON'T
TAKE WHAT YOU'RE BEING TOLD AT
FACE VALUE BECAUSE A LOTTA TIMES
IF NOT TRUE.
IT IS NOT A LIE OR TO DISK
DISTORTION.
OF WHAT YOU'RE BEING TOLD BUT
ULTIMATELY WHAT WE FACE HERE
TODAY.
IS A DECISION THAT WE HAVE TO
MAKE ON AN ISSUE THAT IS POLLING.
AND IT RAINS THAT COULD PASS
BECAUSE THERE IS NO OPPOSITION
THAT HAS ENOUGH RESOURCES TO
FIGHT IT BACK SO WE LET THIS GO
YEAH YOU'RE RIGHT WE COULD SAY
NO WHAT IS THAT ME WE GET STUCK
WITH THIS INITIATIVE PASSING ON
THE BALLOT.
AND OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS OUR
HAMSTRING FURTHER.
MUCH FURTHER THAN THEY WOULD BE
HAMSTRING IT BY PASSING NESS BUT
THIS ALSO NOW PUTS THE ONUS ON
US.
IT'S TIME FOR US TO STAND UP.
IT'S TIME FOR US TO MAKE THIS
DECISION THIS INDUSTRY WANTED US
TO MAKE THIS CHOICE THIS
INDUSTRY WANTED TO FALL ON US TO
BE THE ONES TO MAKE THE DECISION
AS TO WHETHER OR NOT.
WE HAVE A SODA TAX IN THIS
INDUSTRY WHY THINK IT'S NOW TIME
TO CALL THEM ON IT AND WE BETTER
COME BACK NEXT YEAR AND HOLD ON
THAT COMMITMENT. TO MAKE THAT
CHANGE BECAUSE YOU WANT TO PUT
IT ON US WE'RE GONNA STEP UP
WE'RE GONNA DO THE RIGHT THING
BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT I CAME UP
HERE TO DO IS TO DO THE RIGHT
THING.
AND NOW IT'S PRETTY CLEAR WHAT
THE RIGHT THING TO DO IS THANK
GOD I RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I
BILL.
MISTER HARPER YOUR RECOMMEND.
YEAH I THINK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER SPEAKER IN CHAIR.
I FOR ONE WANT TO STAND UP.
INSTEAD I AM TIRED.
OF THE BASHING OF THE BALLOT
INITIATIVE PROCESS HERE IN THIS
CHAMBER.
THE BALLOT INITIATIVE PROCESS
WAS INTENDED.
BYPASS A CORRUPTED STATE
LEGISLATURE.
THE WHOLE POINT OF THE BALLOT
INITIATIVE IS TO BE ABLE TO HAVE
THE PEOPLE DIRECTLY VOTE ON
ISSUES [inaudible]
WITH OUT.
HAVING THIS BODY INTERFERING
WITH IT.
AND I WANT TO AVOID SITUATIONS
IN THIS PARTICULAR ISSUE.
AS WELL AS PEOPLE WHO WANT TO
WOULD WANT TO QUOTE REFORM IT
WHICH REALLY MEANS TO HAMSTRING
THE BALLOT ISSUE PROCESS WE
ALREADY HAVE IT SET THE BALLOT
INITIATIVES BUT FOR BY THE
CITIZENS.
ARE PUSH IN THE GENERAL ELECTION
BALLOT RATHER THAN THE PRIMARY
ELECTION BALLOT IN A WHOLE
SERIES OF OTHER LAWS BY THE
STATE LEGISLATURE TO TRY TO
HAMSTRING IT.
AND TO TRY TO OBSTRUCT IT.
WHICH I BELIEVE IS ABSOLUTELY
WRONG WE NEED TO BE PROTECTORS
OF THE RIGHTS OF THE PEOPLE
PROTECTORS OF THE VOTERS.
NOT OBSTRUCT ERRORS OF THE
VOTERS.
NOW I HEARD THE MEMBER FROM SAN
JOSE TALK ABOUT THIS PROCESS IS
BEING A SHAKEDOWN IF YOU WILL
NOT FIND IT COMICAL.
THEY'RE TRYING TO AVOID BEING
OVERTAXED IS CONSIDERED A
SHAKEDOWN BY SOME MEMBERS OF THE
LEGISLATURE BUT THAT'S JUST THE
GENERAL NATURE OF THIS
POPULATION THAT SEATED AND IF IN
THIS BODY.
BUT IF YOU BELIEVE IT'S A
SHAKEDOWN IF YOU BELIEVE IT'S A
CORRUPTION YOU DO HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY.
NOW I FOR ONE AND MUCH MORE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE BALLOT
INITIATIVE PROCESS.
I RECOGNIZE THIS QUOTE UNQUOTE
DEAL CAN EASILY BE UNDONE BY
MANY OF THE MEMBERS HERE.
WITH THE FORTY ONE VOTE OF FORTY
ONE VOTE --
MARGIN ODD NEXT YEAR THE YEAR
AFTER OR THE YEAR AFTER YOU
DON'T NECESSARILY HAVE A
THIRTEEN OR TWELVE YEAR PROCESS
TO JUST GOING ON DO IT.
BUT THE BALLOT INITIATIVE ON THE
OTHER HAND.
THAT CAN ONLY BE UNDONE BY THE
VOTERS THEMSELVES.
AND THAT'S WHY I THINK THERE'S
GREAT VALUE IN THIS.
IF YOU FEEL THIS IS A SHAKEDOWN.
IF YOU FEEL YOU HAVE A HOBSON'S
CHOICE.
DON'T CRY YOUR CROCODILE PEERS
AT ME.
YOU WILL HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
VOTE NO YOU HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
TO VOTE YOUR CONSCIENCE
[inaudible]
DO SO.
IN FRONT OF ALL THE FOLKS THAT
WERE IN FRONT OF IN THE GALLERY
TODAY ONE OF FULLER DAYS THAT
I'VE SEEN HERE.
DON'T VOTER CORRUPTED VOTE YOU
HAVE THE ABILITY TO VOTE YOUR
FEELINGS YOUR CONSCIENCE YOUR
PHILOSOPHY DON'T BE CORRUPTED
VOTE HOW YOU FEEL [inaudible]
DOCTOR QUIRK.
THE BALLOT INITIATIVE PROCESS
WAS MEANT FOR CITIZENS TO BYPASS
THE LEGISLATURE NOT BILLIONAIRES
AND MAJOR CORPORATIONS THAT WAS
CLEARLY THE INTENT.
BUT LET ME TELL YOU WHY YOU
SHOULD VOTE FOR THIS BILL.
WELL THE PEOPLE WHO HAVE PUT ON
SODA TAXES ARE QUITE WELL
MOTIVATED THE FACT IS THERE'S
MORE SUGAR PER OUNCE.
IN A WELCH'S GRAPE JUICE AND ONE
OF MY SEAT MINIMIZE NEARBY SEAT
MEMBERS JUST TO HAVE ME LOOK AT
THIS.
THERE'S MORE SUGAR PER OUNCE IN
THE WELCH'S GRAPE JUICE THAN
THERE IS IN THE SODA.
THERE'S ALMOST AS MUCH SUGAR PER
OUNCE IN THE ORANGE JUICE AS
THERE IS IN THE SODA.
SO JUST PARA HAVING A TAX ON
SODA.
IT DRIVES IT PEOPLE THE ARTIST
USES DOING NOTHING [inaudible]
FURTHER.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE DEMOGRAPHIC
INFORMATION.
IN THE FIFTIES WHEN OP MY MOM
GODDESS SUGARY SODA EVERY WEEK
WE ALL DRANK IT.
WE DIDN'T BECOME OBESE WE DID
NOT -- GET
DIABETES TYPE TWO DIABETES
HOWEVER.
AS THE ARTIFICIAL SWEETENERS
WERE DEVELOPED.
WE NOW SEE.
PEOPLE GETTING DIABETES PEOPLE
BEING OBESE.
THERE ARE GOOD SCIENTIFIC
REASONS FOR THIS.
WHEN YOU TAKE CARE AND AND
ARTIFICIALLY DRAPED ARTIFICIALLY
SWEETENED DRANK?
YOUR BODY SAYS OH I TASTED MY
MOUTH I TASTED MY STOMACH.
LET'S GIVE ASSUME INSULIN.
THAT INSULIN ISN'T NEEDED IT CAN
LEAD TO INSULIN RESISTANCE.
IT CAN ALSO LEAD. TO OBESITY
BECAUSE NOW.
YOUR BLOOD SUGARS DOWN SO WHAT
HAPPENS WHEN YOUR BLOOD SUGARS
DOWN YOU'RE HUNGRY AND YOU EAT.
SO IF WE'RE GOING TO HAVE A TAX
IT SHOULD BE ON ALL THESE THINGS
SUGARY DRINKS [inaudible]
ARM.
ARTIFICIALLY SWEETENED DRINKS
[inaudible]
AND FRUIT JUICE THEY ARE ALL
DANGEROUS THEY'RE ALL CAUSING US
PROBLEMS SAU I THINK THIS IS A
GOOD VOTE RIGHT NOW.
I AGREE I I KNOW THAT NOT ALL IN
THE MEDICAL INDUSTRY ARE GOING
TO AGREE WITH ME ON THIS BUT
THERE'S GOOD SCIENCE BEHIND IT.
AND FURTHER.
THE USE OF ARTIFICIALLY
SWEETENED OF OF SUGAR IS
ACTUALLY GOING DOWN [inaudible]
A DIABETES.
AND OBESITY ARE STILL GOING UP.
WE KNOW FROM STUDIES THE GOING
ON TO ARTIFICIALLY.
SWEETEN DRINKS DOES NOT CAUSE
YOU TO LOSE WEIGHT.
SO I WOULD URGE A YES VOTE THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU DOCTOR QUIRK MISTER
ALLEN.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
SO I'VE HEARD A LOT OF
RELUCTANCE --
ON THIS FOR EVERY A LOT OF
PEOPLE THAT SAY THAT YOU KNOW
THEY THEY'RE FACED WITH THIS
TERRIBLE CHOICE AND THEY CAME UP-HERE TO VOTE FOR MORE TAXES.
AND NOW THEY'RE THEY'RE STUCK
WITH VOTING TO STOP TAXES WILL
LOOK GUYS I WOULD SAY HAVE SOME
BACKBONE VOTE YOUR CONSCIENCE AS
MY COLLEAGUE FROM HUNTINGTON
BEACH JUST SAID.
IF YOU'RE SO OPPOSED TO NOT
RAISING TAXES WHAT AGAINST THIS
AND AND FEEL FREE TO RAISE TAXES
AS YOU TYPICALLY DO IN THIS
CHAMBER.
NOW LET LET'S ALSO TALK ABOUT
THE PROCESS HELP IS WHAT HE'LL
TALK ABOUT THE SO CALLED DEAL
BUT I THINK A LOT OF YOU MIGHT
NOT BE FAMILIAR WITH WHAT THE
DEAL IS.
LET'S TALK ABOUT THIS DEAL IS
THERE IS AN INITIATIVE WHOSE
SIGNATURES ARE LIKELY GOING TO
QUALIFY FOR THE BALLOT WHICH
REQUIRE A TWO THIRDS VOTE.
OF THE CITY COUNCILS AND OTHER
IN THOSE CITIES TO RAISE TAXES
ACROSS THE CITIES IN CALIFORNIA
THAT'S WITH THIS INITIATIVE
WOULD DO MANY OF THE TAXES CAN
BE RAISED RIGHT NOW WITH
MAJORITY ONLY VOTES.
NOW AS WE KNOW TAXES CONTINUE TO
GO UP IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
SO THIS ISSUE IT WOULD BE A
GREAT THING IT DOESN'T SAY YOU
CAN'T RAISE TAXES.
IT WOULD YOU SAY THE UNION
OVERWHELMING REASON TO RAISE
TAXES IN ORDER TO GET IT PASSED
YOUR LOCAL CITIES.
I THINK THIS IS A GREAT THING WE
SHOULD ALL THINK IS A GREAT
THING BECAUSE WE SHOULD ALL
ENCOURAGE THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA HAVE AS MUCH SAY IS
POSSIBLE.
IN THIS DEAL WAS PUT TOGETHER
APPARENTLY BY THE CALIFORNIA
BUSINESS ROUNDTABLE.
AND APPARENTLY THEY ARE NOW
TRYING TO CUT A DEAL.
YOU TAKE THIS OFF THE BALLOT
WHICH WOULD DENY THE ABILITY OF
CALIFORNIANS TO STOP TAX
INCREASES IN THEIR LOCAL CITIES.
IN EXCHANGE FOR THIS DEAL IN
FRONT OF US THIS BILL IN FRONT
OF US WHICH WOULD STOP TAX
INCREASES ON GROCERY ITEMS FOR
THE NEXT THIRTEEN YEARS.
NO THIS IS A TERRIBLE DEAL IS A
DEAL WITH THE DEVIL.
BECAUSE THE BOTTOM LINE IS
ANYTHING THIS LEGISLATURE GIVES
IN THIS DEAL CAN BE TAKEN AWAY
IN JANUARY OF NEXT YEAR WITH THE
MAJORITY VOTE BILL.
IT'S STUPID THERE'S NO REASON TO
MAKE A DEAL LIKE THIS.
WHY DON'T WE ALLOW THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA TO GET THE RIGHT TO
DECIDE AS WAS PREVIOUSLY
MENTIONED THE BALLOT INITIATIVE
PROCESS IS DIRECT DEMOCRACY IF
YOU WANT TO CALL YOURSELF A
DEMOCRAT?
WHAT COULD BE MORE DEMOCRATIC
THAN A DIRECT DEMOCRACY POLICY
PUT IN PLACE BY HIRAM WALKER IN
NINETEEN OH SIX GIVING THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA THE ABILITY
TO DIRECTLY DECIDE WHAT IS BEST
FOR THEM?
NOW AS FOR THE SPECIAL INTERESTS
OUT THERE AS FOR THE S. C. AYE
YOU IS ON ONE SIDE OF THIS DEAL
AND THE CALIFORNIA BUSINESS
ROUNDTABLE WOODS APPARENTLY ON
THE OTHER SIDE OF THIS DEAL.
A VERY SIMPLE IN A VERY CLEAR
MESSAGE THIS IS ABOUT THE PEOPLE
OF CALIFORNIA IS ABOUT GIVING
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA THE
RIGHT TO DECIDE WHAT'S BEST. FOR
THEM THIS BILL IS ACTUALLY A
GREAT BILL I THINK WE SHOULD
ABSOLUTELY STOP TAX INCREASE ON
GROCERY ITEMS THE NEXT THIRTEEN
YEARS.
THE BALLOT ISSUE IT IS A GREAT
BALLOT INITIATIVE WE SHOULD GIVE
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA THE
RIGHT COUNTY.
THIRDS SUPERMAJORITY TO PASS ANY
NEW TAXES AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
THEY'RE BOTH GREAT I THINK THAT
WE SHOULD VOTE YES ON THIS WE
SHOULD LET THIS INITIATIVE GO
FORWARD.
BUT IF WE ARE FORCED INTO SOME
SORT OF DEAL THERE'S OUT OF OUR
HANDS BECAUSE THE SPECIAL
INTERESTS ARE TRYING TO WORK
AGAINST THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA.
BUT I WOULD TELL EVERY SINGLE
DEMOCRAT THIS CHAMBER TO VOTE
YOUR CONSCIENCE AND VOTE AGAINST
THIS BECAUSE YOU WE ALL KNOW YOU
LOVE TAX INCREASES SO WHY WOULD
YOU VOTE STARTED TODAY.
AND I WOULD SEND A VERY CLEAR
MESSAGE THE CALIFORNIA BIZ
ROUNDTABLE IN ANY OF THE
INTERESTS THAT ARE BEHIND THIS
INITIATIVE DON'T STOP TODAY
ALLOWS GO FOR THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA.
GIVE THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA
THE RIGHT TO DECIDE AS WAS
PREVIOUSLY MENTIONED BY MY
COLLEAGUE FROM WHITTIER
APPARENTLY THERE'S NO MONEY IN
THE OPPOSITION SIDE TO IT CAN BE
A SLAM DUNK IN NOVEMBER.
LET'S GIVE THE PEOPLE THE RIGHT
CALIFORNIA LET'S PUT THE PEOPLE
BACK IN CHARGE OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND YES LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN LET'S TAKE BACK
CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU MISTER ALAN.
HIRAM JOHNSON THANKS YOU FOR THE
REFERENCE.
SEE NO FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE [inaudible]
MR TANG.
YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER JUST
THOUGHT THANK WANT TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUES FOR THERE ARE
[inaudible]
VERY ROBUST CONVERSATION
ULTIMATELY A VOTE FOR THIS
LEGISLATION TODAY.
IS A VOTE TO ALLOW OUR CITIES TO
CONTINUE. TO HAVE THE ABILITY TO
ASK THEIR VOTERS. TO PAY FOR
HEALTHCARE.
A PAVE ROADS TO FIX SCHOOLS. TO
REPAIR PARKS.
THOSE ARE SOME OF THE VERY
CRITICAL SERVICES THAT WE HAVE
BEEN ASKING ARE VOTERS TO DO IN
EACH OF OUR LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
VERY CRITICAL.
CRITICAL SERVICES WE UNDERSTAND
THAT THIS IS A VERY CHALLENGING
VOTE TODAY.
BUT WE ALSO KNOW THAT THIS IS
JUST ONE DAY IN THAT THE FIGHT
WILL CONTINUE ON THIS ISSUE WE
ARE ABSOLUTELY.
NOT DONE AND WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE ON
AB.
EIGHTEEN THIRTY THANK YOU FOR
STAYING WITH THAT [inaudible]
CLARK LIBERAL.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE [inaudible]
CLERK WILL [inaudible]
CLOSER ROLE.
TELL YOU THAT I SIXTY KNOWS.
ONE SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN WITHOUT OBJECTION
IMMEDIATE TRANSMITTAL TO THE
SENATE.
PARDON ME IMMEDIATE TRANSMITTAL
TO THE GOVERNOR
.
AND MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY ROLES SIXTY
THREE AND SEVENTY SEVEN TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHAO TO TAKE UP
AB.
THREE SEVEN FIVE WITHOUT
REFERENCE TO FILE FOR THE
PURPOSE OF CONCURRENCE AND
SENATE AMENDMENTS.
THEY WAS CALDERON MISS WALDRON
WE OPPOSE THAT MOTION MISS
WALDRON WITH HOLDS MEMBERS IS
GONNA BE PROCEDURAL VOTE MISTER
CALDERON.
MOVES AND MISTER BONTA SECONDS.
THAT THE RULES BE SUSPENDED
CLERK WILL.
OPEN THE ROLL-ON CALDERON IS
ASKING FOR I VOTED MISS WALDRON
AND NO.
THE SURE CALDERON IS ASKING FOR
AN AYE VOTE AND MISS WALDRON A
NO VOTE.
THIS IS A PROCEDURAL VOTE
[inaudible]
IS PROCEDURAL.
CALDERON TESTING FOR NOW I MISS
WALDRON.
TAKES FORTY ONE ON THE ROLL
SUSPENSION THE CLERK WELL.
CLOSER ROLL EYES FIFTY TWO KNOWS
TWENTY ONE THE RULES
[inaudible]
ARE SUSPENDED
.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO BE
TAKING UP A. B.. THREE SEVEN
CLERK WILL READ.
SO ME BILL THREE SEVENTY FIVE BY
SOME REMEMBER CHAO AN ACCOLADE
OF PRIVACY [inaudible]
MR SHALL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AB THREE
SEVENTY FIVE THE CALIFORNIA
CONSUMER PRIVACY ACT.
AS A SIMPLE BILL.
IT IS BASED ON THE PRINCIPLE
THAT PEOPLE SHOULD HALF THE
RIGHT TO CONTROL YOUR OWN
PERSONAL DATA AND SHOULD NOT BE
DISCRIMINATED AGAINST FOR
EXERCISING THAT RIGHT.
IF THE BUSINESS WANTS TO COLLECT
INFORMATION ABOUT YOU WHILE
YOU'RE SURFING THE WEB.
AND THEN USE IT FOR REASONS OF
THEIR OWN.
LIKE PROVIDING A SERVICE WAS
SELLING IT.
THEY SHOULD ASK YOUR PERMISSION
FIRST.
IT IS YOUR DATA.
YOUR PRIVACY YOUR CHOICE.
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT ISSUE
BECAUSE ONLINE BUSINESSES HAVE
THE ABILITY TO KNOW A GREAT DEAL
ABOUT A PERSON'S ONLINE
ACTIVITIES.
THE WEBSITES YOU VISIT CAN
REVEAL WHAT WHEN AND HOW LONG
YOU'VE IS A PARTICULAR SITE.
AND THE TYPE OF CONTENT THAT YOU
DOWNLOAD.
THIS CAN REVEAL HIGHLY SENSITIVE
INFORMATION ABOUT YOU INCLUDING
PERSONAL ACTIVITIES POLITICAL OR
RELIGIOUS INTERESTS.
HEALTH OR FINANCIAL PROBLEMS
YOUR GEO LOCATION WHERE YOU GO
WHAT YOU DO.
ALL DAY EVERY DAY.
THAT SHOULD BIGGEST ALL NERVOUS.
THE PREVALENCE OF DATA BREACHES
LIKE CAMBRIDGE ANALYTICA AND
UNCERTAINTY ABOUT WHAT DATA IS
BEING COLLECTED ON US HAVE AGAIN.
PUT TH SPOTLIGHT ON PRIVACY.
CALIFORNIANS ARE NOT ALONE IN
THEIR DESIRE TO HAVE MORE
CONTROL OVER THEIR INFORMATION.
IN FACT A STUDY CONDUCTED BY THE
PEW RESEARCH CENTER IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN FOUND THAT 4% OF THE
PEOPLE SURVEYED.
SAID THAT IT IS VERY IMPORTANT
TO HAVE CONTROL OF THEIR OWN
INFORMATION.
THE SAME STUDY FOUND THAT 64% OF
AMERICANS BELIEVE THAT THE
GOVERNMENT SHOULD DO MORE TO
REGULATE WHAT ADVERTISES DO.
WITH THEIR INFORMATION.
THIS BILL AB THREE SEVENTY FIVE
GIVES CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS
GREATER RIGHTS TO EXERCISE
CONTROL OVER THEIR PERSONAL
INFORMATION.
AND PROVIDES REASONABLE
CERTAINTY THAT.
THERE ARE SAFEGUARDS IN PLACE TO
PROTECT AGAINST ITS MISUSE.
S. CERVICAL A AGAINST CONSUMERS
THE RIGHT TO REQUEST THAT
BUSINESS THIS CLOSE THE
FOLLOWING.
THE TYPE OF PERSONAL INFORMATION
THAT IT COLLECTS WAS CELLS ABOUT
THE CONSUMER.
THE BUSINESS PURPOSES FOR
COLLECTING WHAT'S SELLING THE
INFORMATION.
AND THE CATEGORIES OF THIRD
PARTIES WITH WHOM THE
INFORMATION IS SHARED SOLD OR
DISCLOSED.
IT ALSO GIVES CONSUMERS THE
RIGHT TO REQUEST THAT A BUSINESS
DELETE ANY PERSONAL INFORMATION
COLLECTED ABOUT THEM AND
REQUIRES BUSINESSES TO DIRECT
SERVICE PROVIDERS TO DO THE SAME.
AB THREE SEVEN FIVE ALSO ALIGNS
ITSELF WITH A PROPOSED BALLOT
INITIATIVE BY.
GIVING CONSUMERS THE RIGHT TO
OPT OUT OF THE SALE OF THEIR
PERSONAL INFORMATION WHILE
REQUIRING AFFIRMATIVE CONSENT TO
SELL THE PERSONAL INFORMATION OF
CHILDREN UP TO THE AGE OF
SIXTEEN IT ALSO ENSURES EQUAL
RIGHT TO SERVICE.
MEANING THAT COMPANIES CANNOT
DISCRIMINATE AGAINST PROVIDING
SERVICES TO PEOPLE IF THEY DON'T
WANT THEIR DATA SOLD.
SO WHY DO WE TAKE ON SUCH A BIG
UNDERTAKING.
THE TRUTH IS OUT A LEGISLATIVE
SOLUTION.
UNLIKE THE INITIATIVE PROCESS
PROVISOS THE OPPORTUNITY TO
STRIKE THE APPROPRIATE BALANCE.
BETWEEN PROTECTING PRIVACY
RIGHTS AND THE ABILITY OF
TECHNOLOGY TO INNOVATE AND
PROVIDE RELIABLE SERVICES NOW
AND INTO THE FUTURE.
THE AGREEMENT REACHED WHAT THE
INITIATIVE PROPONENTS TO MOVE
FORWARD WITH A LEGISLATIVE
SOLUTION IS INDEED A SIGNIFICANT
STEP IN PROVIDING CALIFORNIA
CONSUMERS.
WITH MORE CONTROL OVER THEIR
DATA.
CALIFORNIANS SHOULD HAVE THE
RIGHT TO CHOOSE HOW THEIR
PERSONAL INFORMATION IS
COLLECTED AND USED.
AND CALIFORNIANS ACROSS THE
POLITICAL SPECTRUM FEEL THE SAME
WAY.
YOU KNOW I SHOULD HAVE THE
ULTIMATE SAY OVER HALL OUR
INFORMATION IS USED NOT THE
COMPANIES IT REALLY IS THAT
SIMPLE.
WOULD THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THEY WAS CHAO MATURE OBERNOLTE
RECOMMENDS.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
IN SUPPORT OF AB THREE SEVENTY
FIVE I THINK THE ISSUE OF
DIGITAL PRIVACY IS A
TREMENDOUSLY IMPORTANT ONE AND
IT WILL BECOME.
EVEN MORE IMPORTANT IN THE
DECADES TO COME WHEN THE VARIETY
OF INFORMATION THAT'S COLLECTED
ABOUT US ON THE USES TO WHICH
THAT INFORMATION IS PUT EXPANDS.
I ALSO THINK IT'S VERY
APPROPRIATE THE CALIFORNIA'S
TAKING A LEADERSHIP ROLE IN THIS
ISSUE.
AS THE CRUCIBLE OF COMPANIES
THAT SPECIALIZE IN THE
COLLECTION OF DIGITAL DATA LIKE
FACEBOOK AND GOOGLE AND APPLE.
I THINK WE HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY
TO LEAD.
THE EXAMINATION OF THIS ISSUE.
I ALSO FEEL THAT HERE IN THE
LEGISLATURE IS THE APPROPRIATE
VENUE FOR THIS DEBATE.
I THINK WE CAN DO A BETTER JOB
OF BALANCING THE TRADE OFFS
BETWEEN PROTECTING DIGITAL
PRIVACY ON THE ONE HAND AND
ENCOURAGING COMMERCE ON THE
OTHER.
THROUGH A LEGISLATIVE PROCESS
THEN THROUGH THE INITIATIVE
PROCESS.
AND IF YOU WANT PROOF OF HOW
MUCH PROGRESS HAS BEEN MADE ON
THIS ISSUE.
LOOK AT THE INITIATIVE THAT THIS
ISSUE THAT THIS BILL MS METRO
REPLACE THE INITIATIVES ABOUT
TWO PAGES LONG THIS BILL IS
ALMOST TWENTY PAGES LONG.
SO WE HAVE MADE A TREMENDOUS
AMOUNT OF PROGRESS NO ONE I
THINK THE AUTHOR AND THE
STAKEHOLDERSFOR WORKING SO HARD
ON THIS ISSUE IN THE LAST COUPLE
OF WEEKS.
NOW HAVING SAID ALL OF THAT.
IT'S BEEN A LITTLE BIT
FRUSTRATING FOR ME.
THE PROCESS THAT'S BEEN FOLLOWED
HERE BECAUSE IT IS BEEN AN
ABBREVIATED PROCESS ABBREVIATED
BY THE LEGISLATIVE DEADLINES
REQUIRED. TO WITHDRAW THAT
INITIATIVE FROM THE BALLOT IN
NOVEMBER.
I STILL HAVE SOME SERIOUS
CONCERNS WITH THIS BILL.
I'M CONCERNED ABOUT THE PRIVATE
RIGHT OF ACTION IN THE BILL.
BEING USED FOR PURPOSES BEYOND
THE SCOPE OF THE DATA
PROTECTIONS IN THIS BILL SO I
THINK THAT LANGUAGE THESE TO BE
TAKEN UP.
AND ALSO IN THE PRIVACY HEARING
YESTERDAY ON THE BILL.
THERE WERE SOME SERIOUS CONCERNS
RAISED BY STAKEHOLDERS OF
POTENTIAL UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES OF THE BILL SO IT'S
CLEAR THAT WE ARE GOING TO NEEDS
TO DO SOME WORK.
ON IMPLEMENTATION OF FIXES FOR
THIS BILL IN THE NEXT EIGHTEEN
MONTHS AND I'M THANKFUL THAT WE
HAVE A DELAYED IMPLEMENTATION
THE GIVES US THE TIME TO DO THAT.
SO THE AUTHORS OF THE BILL HAVE
MADE A COMMITMENT TO WORK WITH A
STAKEHOLDERS TO RESOLVE SOME OF
THOSE ISSUES.
IN THE COMING MONTHS AND WHAT
THEY'RE COMMITTED IN PLACE AYE
URGENT AYE VOTE ON AB THREE
SEVENTY FIVE TODAY.
THEY MISS OBERNOLTE.
STIR LOW YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS I PREACH THAT DO
NEED TO SPEAK ON ASSEMBLY BILL.
THREE SEVEN FIVE OF FIRST OFF
I'D LIKE TO COMMEND THE AUTHORS
OF FOR THEIR DILIGENCE IN THE
PASSION IN THIS ISSUES.
AND THE LEVEL OF EXPERTISE IT IS
NO.
SECRET THAT THEY HAVE TAKEN A
GREAT DEAL OF TIME TO INVEST
WITH.
SOME OF THE KEY STAKEHOLDERS IN
ADDRESSING FORWARD.
AS WE'VE JUST HEARD HOWEVER
ABOUT THE INITIATIVE PROCESS OUT
VIV ONLY HAD THREE WORKING DAYS
TO TAKE A LOOK AT THESE ISSUES.
AND WITH THEIR RESPECTIVE RA
ACKNOWLEDGING THAT THIS HAS WIDE
IMPLICATIONS ON COMPANIES THAT
ARE NOT JUST SIMPLY IN THE
BORDERS OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA NOT JUST IN THE
NATION BUT GLOBALLY.
THIS IS DUE DILIGENCE TO ENSURE
THAT WE HAVE THE APPROPRIATE
AMOUNT OF TIME TO MY KNOWLEDGE
NO OTHER MEMBER OF THIS
LEGISLATURE REPRESENTING THE
SILICON VALLEY REGION WAS
CONSULTED.
IN THESE DISCUSSIONS AND OF THE
SAME TIME WE JUST HEARD
PREVIOUSLY ON THIS PROCESS THAT
THERE IS A CHALLENGING.
EXERCISE THAT WE SEE HERE WHICH
IS THAT OF THE LEGISLATIVE BODY
AND OBLIGATIONS ON A FAIR
PROCESS.
AND IT IS TO NOTE THAT WHILE
THIS IS NOT A PERFECT SOLUTION
WITH RESPECT TO PROCESS MY DEAR
FRIEND AND COLLEAGUE FROM BIG
BEAR ALSO ECHO THE COMMENTS THAT
IT IS THIS.
THE DUTY OF THIS BODY TO ADDRESS
THESE OUTSTANDING ISSUES GOING
FORWARD AND I ALSO HAVE HEARD IN
PREVIOUS CONVERSATIONS UP FROM
THE AUTHORS THAT THERE ARE.
A SIGNIFICANT COMMITMENTS IN
ADDRESSING THESE ISSUES MOVING
FORWARD IN GOOD FAITH OUT SO
AGAIN WHILE THIS IS NOT A
PERFECT PROCESS IT IS ONE THAT I
THINK IS.
A WHAT.
AN OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO
ACCOMODATE OF MY FELLOW
COLLEAGUES IN THE DEAR DEAR WORK
OF MY FRIENDS ARE HERE AND I
WOULD ALSO RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
A VOTE.
THEY MEMBERS IF YOU'D LIKE TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE DEBATE PLEASE
RAISE YOUR MICROPHONES NOW
MEMBERS PLEASE RAISE YOUR
MICROPHONES NOW.
BERMAN YOUR RECOGNIZE.
THINK YOU OF MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
AB -- THREE
SEVENTY FIVE BUT WANT TO
DISAGREE WITH THE COMMENT THAT
THIS IS A SIMPLE BILL.
THIS IS A SIMPLE CONCEPT --
BUTTON THAT POLICY BUT IT'S A
VERY COMPLICATED POLICY.
AS VERY NEW WANTS POLICIES --
THAT HAVEN'T BEEN IN PRINT FOR
VERY LONG AND WE'RE STILL
LEARNING ABOUT SOME OF THE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES THAT
MIGHT OCCUR.
UNDER THIS POLICY JUST YESTERDAY
WE HEARD FROM THE NEWSPAPER
PUBLISHERS ASSOCIATION ABOUT HOW
THIS MIGHT INHIBIT THEIR ABILITY
TO DO INVESTIGATIVE REPORTING.
ó AND WORK WITH SOURCES THAT
WAS SOMETHING THAT I HADN'T
ANTICIPATED AS BEING A
CONSEQUENCE --
BUT WHEN THEY READ THE BILL THEY
REALIZED THAT THAT IT COULD
APPLY TO THEM IN A WAY THAT I'M
SURE WAS NOT INTENDED BY THE
AUTHORS.
OF THE BILL SO --
WHILE I RISE IN SUPPORT I WANT.
TO VERY MUCH A WORK IN PROGRESS --
THAT IMPROVEMENTS WILL BE NEED
TO BE MADE OVER THE COMING
MONTHS AND AND YEAR EIGHTEEN
MONTHS UNTIL IMPLEMENTATION --
AND THAT WE NEED TO WORK WITH
INDUSTRY ALL INDUSTRIES --
TO IDENTIFY HOW THIS MIGHT APPLY
TO THEM I MAKE SURE THAT ONLY
APPLIES TO THEM IN THE WAYS THAT
WE INTENDED AND NOT UNINTENDED --
SO WITH THAT I URGE YOUR SUPPORT
FOR A BI THREE SEVENTY FIVE
KNOWING THAT --
WE WILL IMPROVE IT OVER THE NEXT
EIGHTEEN MONTHS.
THEY MISSED BERMAN.
MS MELENDEZ YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER --
I JUST I HAVE A QUESTION OF THE
AUTHORED BY ME.
WITHOUT OBJECTION.
THANK YOU --
SO WE HAD A BRIEF COMMERCE
COMMUNICATION YESTERDAY ABOUT
SOME CONCERNS ABOUT THIS BILL
AND I JUST WANTED TO HAVE YOU ON
THE RECORD AS INDICATING WHETHER
OR NOT YOU ARE WILLING --
TO ALONG WITH YOUR YOUR CO
AUTHOR IN THE SENATE --
WORKING WITH THE STAKEHOLDERS TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE EXISTING
PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION ON IS
NOT EXPANDED AND THAT THERE ARE
SOME INFORMATIONAL HEARINGS
BETTER HELD PRIOR TO THE
ENACTMENT OF THIS LEGISLATION
SHOULD I GET THROUGH TODAY JUST
SO THAT WE MAKE SURE.
WE HAVE --
CLOSED ALL THE GAPS AND EVERYONE
IS SATISFIED I JUST WANTED TO
ASK IF YOU HAVE MADE THAT
COMMITMENT TO TO WORK ON THOSE
ISSUES I WILL ADDRESS THAT IN MY
CLOSING ARGUMENTS.
THANK YOU IS ONE THAT'S MISTER
MURATSUCHI.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF MY FRIEND FROM
MODERATE PARK.
AND THANK HIM.
FOR LEADING THIS FIGHT. FOR SO
LONG.
YOU KNOW WE ALL HAVE A STAKE.
AND REGAINING CONTROL OVER OUR
PERSONAL INFORMATION.
WE ALL HAVE A STAKE IN OUR
PRIVACY RIGHTS.
AND THIS FIGHT.
ITS NOT NEW WE KNOW THAT OUR
CALLING FOR MONTEREY PARK HAS
BEEN FIGHTING THIS FIGHT
[inaudible] FOR YEARS.
AND SO WHILE THIS ISSUE.
WHY WHY THIS?
THEN THE BILLS THAT NEED TO BE
WORKED OUT [inaudible]
SURE [inaudible]
THE TECH INDUSTRY WILL BE COMING
BACK WHERE FOR MANY LEGISLATIVE
PROPOSALS.
AND I'D LOOK FORWARD TO ENGAGING
WITH.
YOU KNOW THE ENGINE OF OUR
STATE'S ECONOMY THE INNOVATION
ECONOMY THE HIGH TECH INDUSTRY.
BUT THIS ISN'T IMPORTANT FIRST
STEP.
AND I THANK MY FRIEND FROM
MONTEREY PARK FOR LEADING THIS
CHARGE AND I ASKED.
ALL OF YOU TO SUPPORT AB.
THREE SEVEN FIVE THEY MISS
MURATSUCHI OTHER MEMBERS WISHING
TO SPEAK PLEASE RAISE YOUR
MICROPHONES [inaudible]
OTHER MEMBERS.
THANK YOU MEMBERS MISTER SPEAKER
HERE ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS I ALSO RISE IN SUPPORT
OF AB.
THREE SEVENTY FIVE A
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT TO PRIVACY.
IS UNIQUE TO CALIFORNIA AND HAS
SERVED AS THE BASIS FOR THE MANY
GROUNDBREAKING PRIVACY LAWS THAT
HAVE BEEN AT ENACTED BY THE
LEGISLATURE OVER THE YEARS.
AB THREE SEVENTY FIVE
ESTABLISHES THE MOST ROBUST
CENTER PRIVACY PROTECTIONS IN
THE UNITED STATES AND RIGHTFULLY
PUTS BACK IN THE HANDS OF THE
LEGISLATURE.
THE AUTHORITY TO REVIEW ALTAR
AND PASS PRIVACY LAWS.
THE INITIATIVE PROCESS AS A TOOL
FOR MAKING LAWS IS NOT PERFECT
OR IDEAL.
AS WE'VE SEEN IN MULTIPLE
DEBATES TODAY.
BUT I CAN SPUR OF THE
LEGISLATURE TO ACT ON ISSUES
THAT CHALLENGE US.
I WANT TO COMMEND THE AND
INITIATIVES PROPONENTS FOR THEIR
WORK TO PROTECT CALIFORNIA'S
PRIVACY AND THEIR RECOGNITION
THAT THE BEST VENUE TO
EFFECTIVELY EFFECTUATE LAS.
IS THIS HOUSE I ALSO WANT TO
COMMEND THE CHAIR OF OUR PRIVACY
COMMITTEE.
AND IS STAFF OF THE MONUMENT
WORK ON THIS BILL.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MR CHOW.
YOU MAY CLOSE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OF MISTER SPEAKER.
LET ME BEGIN BY THANKING ALL OF
MY COLLEAGUES A AND THE SPEAKER
FOR THEIR COMMENTS.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN TODAY WE
HAVE A CHANCE TO MAKE A
DIFFERENCE.
BY GIVING CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS
FULL OF THEIR OWN DATA.
BEFORE US ARE TWO OPTIONS.
OPTION ONE WE DO NOTHING AND
TAKE OUR CHANCES WITH THE
PRIVACY INITIATIVE.
IT'S REQUIRED 70% OF THE
MEMBERSHIP.
OF THE LEGISLATURE TO AMEND.
OR OPTION TO WE VOTE YES ON AB
THREE SEVENTY FIVE TO PROTECT
CHILDREN AND CONSUMERS BY GIVING
THEM THE RIGHT TO ACCESS THE
LEAD.
AND TO SAY NO TO THE SALE OF
THEIR PERSONAL INFORMATION
WITHOUT BEING DISCRIMINATED
AGAINST.
WE HEARD COMMENTS ABOUT THE
PROCESS BEING TO RASH.
AND NOT INCLUSIVE.
I'M THE FIRST ONE TO ADMIT THAT
THE PROCESS COULD BE BETTER IF
WE HAD MORE TIME.
NEVERTHELESS WITHIN THE SHORT
TIME SPAN WE HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
REACH OUT TO BUILD CONSENSUS
WITH MANY STAKEHOLDERS. TO
IMPROVE UPON THE LEGISLATION.
WE ALSO HEARD TO THE BILL ITSELF
MAYBE FLAW.
THE BILL MAY NOT BE PERFECT AND
COULD HAVE BEEN BETTER IF WE HAD
MORE TIME.
YET IT IS THE WORK PRODUCT OF
NUMEROUS PEOPLE SPENDING
HUNDREDS OF HOURS REACHING OUT
AND ATTEMPTING TO BUILD
CONSENSUS.
IT IT'S A WORK PRODUCT IN THE
THAT THE INITIATIVE PROPONENTS
FEEL COMFORTABLE WITH IN ORDER
TO WITHDRAW THE INITIATIVE FROM
THE BALLOT.
IT IS ALSO SOMETHING THAT WOULD
CLOSELY TRACK THE EUROPEAN
PRIVACY MODEL GDP ARE.
IT ALSO ADDRESSES PART OF THE
PROBLEM THAT WE SAW IN CAMBRIDGE
ANALYTICA.
IT IS A FINE PRODUCT THAT COULD
MOVE THE BALL FORWARD IN
ADVANCING THE PRIVACY
PROTECTIONS OF CONSUMERS AND PUT.
CALIFORNIA AHEAD OF THE CURVE.
YEP I WON AGAIN COMMIT MYSELF TO
WORKING WITH ALL STAKEHOLDERS TO
SEE IF AND HOW WE COULD FINE
TUNE THIS BILL BEFORE IT'S ME
IMPLEMENTATION DATE OF JANUARY
FIRST. TWENTY TWENTY MY HOPE
ALSO IS THAT ANY.
TECHNICAL CLEANUPS EMERGING ARE
THAT THE REQUIRED EMERGING --
CLEAN UP WILL BE DONE THIS YEAR.
FOLKS SELL DATA BREACHES IN
HACKING ACTIVITIES ARE EXPLODING
EXPONENTIALLY WE NEED TO DO
SOMETHING ABOUT IT NOW.
IT IS TIME FOR CALIFORNIA TO
AGAIN STEP UP TO THE PLATE.
AND BE A LEADER IN PROTECTING
OUR PRIVACY WHICH IS CLEARLY
ENSHRINED IN OUR CONSTITUTION.
IT IS TIME FOR US TO PRESERVE
THOSE RIGHTS.
THE FUTURE OF YOUR DATA AND THAT
OF YOUR CHILDREN IS AT STAKE.
WE GOT I ALSO WANT TO SHARE WITH
YOU THAT.
THIS BILL JUST PASSED THE SENATE
ABOUT TWENTY MINUTES AGO.
I BIPARTISAN MANNER THIRTY SIX
TWO ZERO WITHOUT I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOU FOR YOUR AYE VOTE THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU MISS SHALL AND WITH
ACT LIKE LOCAL ROLL-ON MEMBERS
SO.
IS ARE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRED OF
THOSE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLERK WELL.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THE
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE OUT I SIXTY NINE
KNOWS ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS.
OUR CAN KURT AND WITHOUT
OBJECTION IMMEDIATE TRANSMITTAL
TO THE GOVERNOR.
MEMBERS WE HAVE SPECIAL GAS
REMAINING IN THE CHAMBER.
WE HAVE VERY SPECIAL GUESTS
REMAINING IN THE CHAMBER
[inaudible]
MR [inaudible]
DAVID CHIU.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
SPECIAL GUESTS INTRODUCTION
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER OUT
COLLEAGUES IT IS AN HONOR FOR ME
TO WELCOME --
TO OUR FLOOR TO RESIDENTS FOR MY
CITY WHO CAME FROM HUMBLE
BACKGROUNDS AND HAVE RECENTLY
ATTAINED.
TOP LEADERSHIP POSITIONS IN THE
CITY AND COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO.
ARE THE FIRST IS A GENTLEMEN WHO
GREW UP IN A FOSTER FAMILY.
WAS EDUCATED AND GRADUATED FROM
TOP SCHOOLS IN OUR COUNTRY.
BECAME A COMMUNITY ADVOCATE FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
BECAME THE PRESIDENT OF OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
BOARD IN SAN FRANCISCO AS IT
LGBT LEADER RAN FOR THE
SUPERVISOR SEE THAT WAS ONCE
HELD BY HARVEY MILK.
I WANT TO WELCOME TO THE FLOOR
OF THE ASSEMBLY THE NEWEST
MEMBER OF THE SAN FRANCISCO
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS RAPHAEL
MANDOLIN.
OUR SECOND GUEST IS SOMEONE WHO
GREW UP IN AN INCREDIBLY
CHALLENGING ENVIRONMENT SHE WAS
RAISED BY HER GRANDMOTHER.
IN PUBLIC HOUSING IN SAN
FRANCISCO.
SHE BECAME A COMMUNITY ADVOCATE
RAN A COMMUNITY CENTER IN THE
HEART OF OUR CITY.
SHE JOINED ME ON THE SAN
FRANCISCO BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
AND SUCCEEDED ME AS PRESIDENT OF
THE SAN FRANCISCO BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS.
ON JUNE FIFTH SHE MADE HISTORY
IN OUR CITY.
AS SHE WAS ELECTED AS THE SECOND
WOMAN IN OUR CITY'S HISTORY AND
AS THE FIRST AFRICAN AMERICAN
WOMAN TO HOLD THE POST IN TWO
WEEKS YOU WILL BE SWORN IN.
AS THE FORTY FIFTH MAYOR OF THE
CITY AND COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO
MY GOOD FRIEND LONDON
.
THREE IMAGE YOU'RE HOLDING YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I JUST
LIKE TO JOIN AND VERY QUICKLY
AND WITH MY COLLEAGUE FROM SAN
FRANCISCO AND ON BEHALF OF THE
THE BLACK CAUCUS TO CAN GRADUATE
[inaudible]
REGULATE --
MAYOR AGREED IN HER ACCESSIBLE
VENTURES AS MAYOR --
EARLIER THIS AFTERNOON WE HAD
SEVENTEEN COUNTRIES REPRESENTED
FROM AFRICA AND YOUNG PEOPLE WHO
ARE HERE.
WHO I KNOW WOULD HAVE BEEN VERY
INSPIRED TO HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SEE THIS PART OF OUR?
OF OUR MEETING BUT I JUST WANTED
TO JOIN IN AND CONGRATULATE HER
AND LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THERE'S A MOVE
.
FOR MEMBERS ONCE QUORUM CALL IS
LIFTED THE FOLLOWING COMMITTEES
WILL BE MEETING IMMEDIATELY.
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION ROOM.
FORTY TWO TWO INSURANCE IN ROOM
FOUR FOUR SEVEN AND JUDICIARY
AND ROOM.
FOR THREE SEVEN IMMEDIATELY UPON
QUORUM CALL BEING LIFTED.
WE ARE AT CONSENT CALENDAR DOES
ANY MEMBER WAS TO REMOVE AN ITEM
FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR SEEING
AND HEARING NONE.
CLERK WILL READ THE SECOND A
CONSENT CALENDAR ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION TO A ONE
BY SOME REMEMBER FONG ANOTHER'S
RELATIVE.
JESSE L. ASA BETTER MEMORIAL
REST AREA.
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR AND WE WILL
LEAVE IT OPEN MEMBERS TAKE YOUR
PHOTO [inaudible]
CLICK LIBERAL.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED WISH TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHICH TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE A WISH TO VOTE
THIS IS THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS OUT OF THE
THIS IS CONSENT CALENDAR
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE THE ROLE.
I SEVENTY THREE KNOWS.
ZERO INSANE CALENDARS ADOPTIVE.
CLERK READ THE REMAINING ITEMS
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
TWO FIFTY I SEVENTY THREE NO
ZERO SENATE BILL TWELVE SEVENTY
I SEVENTY THREE NO ZERO SENATE
BILL TENET.
I SEVENTY THREE KNOWS HERE
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
NINETY TWO I SEVENTY THREE NO
ZERO CYNICAL CURRENT RESOLUTION
ONE OF FIVE I SEVENTY THREE NO
ZERO SENATE CURRENT RESOLUTION.
ONE TWELVE I SEVENTY THREE NO
ZERO INCIDENT CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION ONE TWENTY FOUR I
SEVENTY THREE NO.
ZERO IN THE ABSENCE OF OBJECTION
THE QUORUM CALL IS LIFTED.
AND WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
PREVIOUSLY ANNOUNCED
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY.
AGAIN MEMBERS.
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION ROOM
FORTY TWO A TWO INSURANCE IN
ROOM FOUR FOUR SEVEN JUDICIARY
IN ROOM [inaudible]
FOUR THIRTY SEVEN NOW MEETING.
THE FOLLOWING MEMBERS WERE
GRANTED PRIOR PERMISSION TO
SPEAK ON A GERMAN IN MEMORY.
MEMBERS I WOULD ASK THAT YOU
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS OR TAKE
YOUR CONVERSATIONS.
OFF OF THE FLOOR
.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS.
OR TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF
OF THE GREEN CARPET.
WE HAVE ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY
.
WE ARE AND ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY MEMBERS IN THE REAR OF
THE CHAMBER.
MISTER O'DONNELL YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
I RISE TODAY TO ADJOURN THE
MEMORY OF LONG BEACH FIRE
CAPTAIN DAVE ROSA.
A DEDICATED PUBLIC SERVANT
FAMILY MAN AND COMMUNITY
VOLUNTEER CAPTAIN ROSA WAS A
VETERAN OF THE LONG BEACH FIRE
DEPARTMENT SERVING THE GREATER
LONG BEACH COMMUNITY. FOR THE
LAST SEVENTEEN YEARS.
HE WAS KILLED IN THE LINE OF
DUTY AND THE EARLY MORNING HOURS
OF MONDAY THIS JUNE TWENTY FIFTH.
CAPTAIN ROSA LEAVES BEHIND A
WIFE. TWO CHILDREN WHO ALL WHERE
THE LOVE OF HIS LIFE.
HE LIVED IN SAN JUAN CAPISTRANO
WHERE HE WAS A BELOVED MEMBER OF
THE COMMUNITY AND ACTIVE LITTLE
LEAGUE VOLUNTEER.
HE PARTICIPATED AS A MANAGER
EMPIRE COCHIN EVEN PAST
PRESIDENT OF US LOCAL LITTLE
LEAGUE.
LITTLE LEAGUE PARENTS REMEMBER
HIM AS A MAN WHO IS GREAT WITH
KIDS.
AND AS ONE WHO UNDERSTOOD THAT
HIS JOB AS A COACH WAS TO
ENCOURAGE KIDS AND NURTURE THEM
TO SUCCESS.
FRIENDS DESCRIBE CABIN ROSE AS A
STAUNCH FAMILY MAN A GOOD
HUSBAND A GOOD FATHER.
AND A TRUE JOY TO BE AROUND
[inaudible]
ENCOURAGING COMPASSIONATE
AND CARING.
THE ULTIMATE SERVANT LEADER.
CAPTAIN ROSA WAS AND ALWAYS WILL
BE WELL WELL RESPECTED BY HIS
DEPARTMENT PEERS.
ESPECIALLY WITH THOSE HE SERVED
WITH AT STATION.
TEN HIS UNTIMELY DEATH IS A LOSS
TO ALL OF US.
HIS FAMILY THE CITY OF LONG
BEACH AND THE SAN JUAN
CAPISTRANO COMMUNITY AND BEYOND.
OUR THOUGHTS AND PRAYERS ARE
WITH CAPTAIN ROSES FAMILY.
AND ALL FIRST RESPONDERS WHO
WORK HARD TO PROTECT US EVERYDAY.
BECAUSE AS THEY WOULD TELL US.
YOU NEVER KNOW WHAT AWAITS YOU
AT THE NEXT CALL YOU ARE
RESPONDING.
TO CAPTAIN ROSA IS SIR'S IS
SURVIVED BY HIS LOVING WIFE AND
TWO SONS HIS BROTHERS AND
SISTERS AT THE LONG BEACH FIRE
DEPARTMENT WHO LOVED HIM GREATLY.
AND THE COMMUNITY THAT LOVED HIM
AS WELL.
THEY WILL MISS HIM FOREVER I ASK
THAT WE ADJOURN THE MEMORY TODAY
OF CAPTAIN DAVE ROSA.
THANK YOU MISTER O'DONNELL
MISTER SPEAKER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR SPEAKER MEMBERS
MEMBERS I ALSO RISE TO ADJOURNED
IN MEMORY OF CAPTAIN DAVE ROSE.
THAT LIKE TO ASSOCIATE MYSELF
WITH THE REMARKS MADE BY MY
COLLEAGUE FROM LONG BEACH.
BY ALL ACCOUNTS CAPTAIN RUSSELL
WAS A LOVING FAMILY MAN A GOOD
FRIEND AND SOMEONE WHO DEVOTED.
IT IS DEPARTMENT SOMEONE WHO'S
DEVOTED HIS DEPARTMENT AND THE
COMMUNITY HE SERVES.
THE LAST PART WAS OBVIOUS WHEN
WITHOUT REGARD FOR HIS OWN
SAFETY HE RAN INTO THAT SENIOR
RESIDENTS TO HELP THOSE WHO
MIGHT BE IN DANGER.
I KNOW WE ALL SEND OUR DEEPEST
SYMPATHY TO CAPTURE US IS FAMILY.
TO HIS FELLOW FIREFIGHTERS IN
LONG BEACH AND ALL AROUND
CALIFORNIA INTO THE MANY FRIENDS
HE LEAVES BEHIND.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
MS BAKER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR GERMANY MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE TODAY TO ADJOURN
IN THE MEMORY OF ARTHUR ALLEN
GASKINS A RESIDENT OF DANVILLE
WHO DIED ON JUNE SEVENTEENTH AT
THE AGE OF NINETY NINE ART.
AS HE WAS KNOWN TO OUR COMMUNITY
WAS BORN ON AUGUST TWENTY NINTH
IN NINETEEN EIGHTEEN AND LEFT
CAN TEXAS.
HE JOINED THE U. S. ARMY IN
NINETEEN FORTY ONE AND SERVED
HONORABLY DURING WORLD WAR TWO
HE WAS STATIONED IN EUROPE WITH
THE THIRTEENTH ARMORED DIVISION.
AND HIS HEROIC AND DISTINGUISHED
SERVICE EARNED HIM THE BRONZE
STAR DURING WORLD WAR.
TWO FOLLOWING THE WAR ARTS SPENT
MANY YEARS LIVINGIN SAN LEANDRO
IN RANCHO MURIETA.
AND WHILE HE WAS LIVING IN SAN
LEANDRO HE WORKED LOWER PIERCING
TRACTOR COMPANY IN PURCHASING
AND ALSO WAS AN HR MANAGER.
HE JUST WAS ONE OF THE MANY
VETERANS WHO CAME BACK FROM
WORLD WAR TWO AFTER VERY
DISTINGUISHED SERVICE AND WENT
RIGHT ON TO LIVE THEIR LIVES --
BUILDING A COMMUNITY HE LATER
TOOK UP RESIDENCE IN DANVILLE
CALIFORNIA IN TWO THOUSAND NINE
AND WAS VERY VERY ACTIVE IN THE
VETERANS OF FOREIGN WARS VFW
POST.
SEVENTY FIVE THE VFW OF COURSE
WE KNOW IS A NONPROFIT VETERANS
SERVICE ORGANIZATION DEDICATED
TO VETERANS SERVICE AND
LEGISLATIVE ADVOCACY HE WAS VERY
VERY INTERCOOLED FOR IT TO THAT
FOR MANY DECADES.
HE SERVED AS A DOCENT
COORDINATOR FOR THE MILITARY
MUSEUM AT THE DANVILLE VETERANS
BUILDING AND TIME WAS JUST NOT
ONLY LOVED BY VETERANS
THROUGHOUT THE DAY. ONE OF THE
LARGEST IN THE BAY AREA OVER
FORTY THOUSAND PEOPLE ATTEND AS
ONE OF ITS MOST HONORED GUESTS
AND THE ENTIRE DANVILLE
COMMUNITY WAS WORKING ON AND
BUILDING A BIG BIRTHDAY PARTY
FOR HIM THIS UPCOMING AUGUST.
ART IS SURVIVED BY HIS DAUGHTER
LYNN HIS STEPDAUGHTER SHARON HIS
GRANDCHILDREN JENNIFER SCOTT'S
LINDSEY AND THOMAS AND HIS GREAT
GRANDCHILDREN JORDAN GRANT KISI.
TANNER MAXWELL AND CALLAN.
ART WILL BE REMEMBERED LONG IN
WEALTH IN THE DANVILLE COMMUNITY
AND HE HAS A WONDERFUL HISTORY
OF PUBLIC SERVICE BOTH FOR THE
LOCAL COMMUNITY AND OUR COUNTRY.
I OFFER MY DEEPEST CONDOLENCES
TO ARTS IN HIS VAN FRIENDS AND
FAMILY ALL THROUGHOUT THE AREA
AND ASK THAT WE HONOR HIM BY
ADJOURNING IN HIS MEMORY TODAY
THANK YOU COLLEAGUES.
THANK YOU MS BAKER.
AND THANK YOU MEMBERS ANNOUNCING.
THAT THE JOINT HEARING OF THE
ASSEMBLY PRIVACY AND CONSUMER
PROTECTION.
AND SENATE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
STATUE IN HEARING HAS BEEN
CANCELED.
ALL OTHER ITEMS REMAINING WILL
BE PASSED RETAIN A MOTION SHALL
BE CONTINUED SEEING AND HEARING
NO FURTHER BUSINESS I'M READY TO
ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO ADJOURN.
MS LA MONDE MOVES MISS BAKER
SECONDS THAT THIS HOUSE STANDS
ADJOURNED UNTIL MONDAY JULY
SECOND AT ONE PM.
WE ARCHER